[Music]
happiness is not a destination happiness
is a Direction so the great news is that
every single person watching can get
happier and the better news is we know
what they can work on to get happier but
they need the knowledge
[Music]
I'm extremely proud to introduce you to
our newest brand partner on check out
their lineup of super comfortable sleek
and durable pieces for yourself at
on.com
well let's let's begin by talking a
little bit about what happiness is how
people get confused about happiness and
think it's something other than what it
actually is and give us a framework for
how to even approach this challenging
subject it's a huge conundrum for people
because there's almost nobody who
doesn't say I want to be happier
most people say I want to be happy to
begin with that's the wrong goal because
you can't be happy happiness is not a
destination happiness is a direction you
can't be I mean for somebody to be truly
happy it would mean that you would need
to eliminate the parts of your life that
are literally keeping you alive like
your negative emotions you need anger
and sadness and disgust and and you need
grief and you need all these things um
to stay alive and deal with the world so
pure happiness shouldn't be the goal but
getting happier is a legitimate goal for
everybody the biggest mistake that
people make is thinking that it's a
feeling and chasing a feeling happiness
is not a feeling it has feelings
associated with it but feelings of
Happiness are really evidence of
Happiness sort of the smell of dinner is
the evidence of dinner it's not dinner
itself it'll be a very disappointing
dinner if it were just you know the
smell of Thanksgiving you know shoot it
into the air and then and that that's
that's what chasing feelings is really
like it's incredibly ephemeral and it's
a terrible thing to live that way to
live trying you know hoping that
tomorrow you'll feel a different way
okay and so the first freeing thing is
that number one don't worry about being
happier let's work on getting happier
it's a project that's number one very
empowering and number two is that it's
not a feeling it's something that you
really can work on it's something it's a
skill you can really get better at so
that's the Prelude to you know how
people see it wrong and how they can be
encouraged to see it correctly and start
to get better at it then the whole
question becomes okay it's not a feeling
what is it and that's a big that's a
controversy in in the world of social
psychology and social science in general
even Neuroscience what is happiness but
as a functional definition you find that
people who have the most well-being in
their lives have balance and abundance
across three things sort of
macronutrients so the protein
carbohydrates and fat of happiness or
enjoyment satisfaction and purpose those
are the three things that people
actually need and none of those things
is as simple as it sounds each one has a
literature of of of science behind it
and has protocols and habits that we can
all pursue and get better at so the
great news is that every single person
watching us can get happier and the
better news is we know what they can
work on to get happier but they need the
knowledge right so this idea that
happiness we can
we can have a debate on how we
particularly Define what it is but the
truth of the matter is that that's less
important than this idea that it is
evidence or uh something that comes
about as a result of these three
macronutrients that we should all pursue
getting better at that will yeah as as a
kind of way of life it's not one
something you do once it's something
that you incorporate into the way that
you're living your life correct right
that will time and again produce that
sensation of Happiness however ephemeral
or fleeting it may be but with some
regularity it will build more of that
into your exactly right exactly right
and these are skills that you can get
better at this is the you know the best
news of all but you have to know what
they are and and it's not
straightforward when you say enjoyment
as one of these that that could create
some confusion it can and the biggest
confusion is especially for people that
are really into improving themselves
through knowledge that they can get on
you know the Rich Roll podcast for
example is they might make the mistake
of thinking that enjoyment is pleasure
and it's absolutely not pleasure is uh
is a limbic phenomenon it's an ancient
phenomenon it's a signal to you that
something is going to be good for your
survival or passing on your genes but
the pursuit of pleasure will not bring
you happiness it will bring you
addiction that's as sure as we're
sitting here is what it will do and the
reason is because it's a fleeting thing
it's a fleeting sensation if you hit the
lever and hit the lever you'll change
your brain chemistry to get really
really good to bring you that pleasure
and that will give you addiction you
know all addictions are are based in a
in an excessive and
um uh unhealthy uh stimulation of
dopamine the neuromodulator dopamine in
the human brain so the the reason that
for example that you know drinking too
much brings pleasure but doesn't bring
happiness is because it doesn't actually
bring enjoyment so this is the key thing
to understand enjoyment has a base and
pleasure but it adds two things it adds
people and memory
so anything that you do that brings
pleasure you do Alone look out as a rule
of thumb anything as pleasurable you do
alone is not going to bring you
happiness you need people involved and
you need memory which is part of your
prefrontal cortex is your executive
function has to be involved in that and
a good example of how we understand this
intuitively you know Anheuser-Busch has
a beer commercial they never have how a
lot of people are using Bud Light which
is pounding a 12-pack alone in their
apartment
that's and the reason that they don't
advertise it that way which is that they
don't want to advertise their product as
a way to get pleasure but not happiness
they have people drinking Bud Light with
their friends or with their family and
making a memory because it's pleasure
feels good plus people Plus
memory and then you actually get
happiness and so this is the way to
think about gambling if you're going to
gamble this is the way to think about
sexual activity this is the way to think
about any of these things that if it's
you know alone and compulsive becomes a
problem but if it's sociable and it
creates memory it actually can be
enhance your happiness everybody who and
I don't drink alcohol you don't drink
alcohol I don't know how to drink
alcohol in a normal way why because I
started drinking alcohol when I was 13
14 years old and it was nothing but
solitary pleasure and I never learned
how to make it into a source of
enjoyment that's the reason that it
became a problem is because I was never
able to use it in a responsible way
where it could enhance my happiness
so if one has addictive Tendencies or is
in recovery how would you frame their
pursuit of enjoyment we can set you know
addictive behaviors and substances aside
but just general
um you know pursuit of of of activities
or or behaviors that are going to
engender more of that in one's life to
begin with the the the the substances or
activities of abuse should be avoided
and part of the reason for that is that
we know that the neural Pathways have
been so ingrained with those substances
and activities that they're they're
inherently dangerous for people now
however there's comorbidity between one
kind of abuse and other kinds of abuse
which is why that that former problem
drinkers tend to become Workaholics or
you know workout Fanatics and they do
all or or for example if you're if you
used to abuse alcohol and go to the
doctor and say I can't sleep he
shouldn't she shouldn't give you
Zolpidem ambient because it'll actually
stimulate the same Pathways you'll
probably get addicted to
you know benzo diazepine drugs or
anything else along those lines so you
got to stay away you got to be careful
you got to be awake you gotta you have
to be have your eyes open so you're not
walking into trouble but anything else
that you like remember you have to do it
with people and make memories it has to
add those two elements anything that
you're I mean again this is rule of
thumb so I'm sure that we could come up
with some sort of an exception of
something that you do by yourself like
you know I Walk Alone in nature okay
fine you know peace that's that's a
different thing but anything that that
has any sort of potential for abuse at
all
make sure that it's not solitary and
make sure it's something that you're
doing consciously so communion and
Consciousness on top of the pleasure and
then you're going to be in pretty good
hands right
um
on to the next one satisfaction yeah
there's a killer you know satisfaction
is such a is such a funny riddle in
human life satisfaction is the joy you
get after struggle you know there's so
much joy you get because of human
endeavor that requires effort and and
humans are made to do hard things humans
are made to work and to get a payoff for
it and the joy the sheer joy that you
get after you do something really hard
which you've done so many I mean as an
ultra endurance athlete I mean this is
the sort of the scenic one odds and lots
of sacrifice lots of pain and then and
then a big payoff but life is like that
if you're going through life and you're
trying to get joy without struggle
you're not going to get that second
macronutrient of Happiness so for
example if you're you know I tell my
students you can cheat on my exam it's
pretty easy to cheat on my exams but if
you get an A you won't feel any
satisfaction from it on the other hand
if you work I mean it's an A on an exam
it's it's meaningless but you'll get a
lot of satisfaction if you worked really
really hard for it that's the first part
which is that it requires struggle to
get that little bit of Joy but the real
riddle about satisfaction is that you
mother nature tells us that if you get
it it's going to last and it doesn't
yeah so Mick Jagger's things I Can't Get
No Satisfaction that's wrong if you
couldn't get it you wouldn't keep trying
and trying and trying like a song goes
the problem is you can't keep No
Satisfaction and and that's the thing
that you never quite figure out and we
understand the brain science behind that
but but we have to once again we have to
diverge from Mother Nature's teachings
or Mother Nature's urges that she gives
us and do something on the Divine path
and and if we do certain things that
feel quite unnatural we can make
satisfaction and stick around what is
the distinction between the temporal the
fleeting temporality of satisfaction and
the brain chemistry of anticipation of
satisfaction because that's really the
driver is it not like I'm working
towards this thing I've done this before
I know I will you know experience that
feeling of satisfaction when I complete
this and that's part of you know the
driving force in that direction you know
your dopamine I can tell yeah that
dopamine is the neuromodulator of the
anticipation of reward it's not reward
per se it's the anticipation of the
reward and that's really part of the
experience that's really part of the
experience and if you're doing something
that doesn't require any struggle you're
not going to get anticipation of reward
in the same way that's how Pleasure and
Pain are so interwoven with each other
and such a complicated phenomenon where
you can't get real pleasure unless there
is also pain in because of this this
really delicate interplay between the
whole between the ideas so as everybody
who watches your podcast knows uh
dopamine is this very potent
neuromodulator that gives us impulse to
do almost anything and it's just it's
ever present in in the way that it it
gives us motivation to do things so for
example we want to I want to get a
sandwich and I think about it at 10
o'clock in the morning and I'm kind of
hungry just thinking about the sandwich
gives me dopamine and then it Dives down
and the fact that it's going down which
I feel gives me motivation to get the
dopamine back up again to go in search
of the sandwich and then around noon I'm
going to go out to the deli my favorite
Deli to get the sandwich and the
dopamine is back up again and then the
deli's closed and it might it just had
tanks and so I look for another Deli and
and then when I finally get it the
dopamine screams upward and then I
finish the sandwich and it goes back
down again and and it's just this
anticipation of reward and reward and
more anticipation in search
that's one of the reasons by the way the
science of happiness is so critical to
understand because when you do you'll
see it in yourself and you can you can
manage it well it's also about balance
right enjoyment could be you could say
you could reframe that as like do cool
with other people with friends or
whatever satisfaction do hard things I
imagine you know I know myself well
enough to know that I'll take that all
the way to the wall like that turns into
perfectionism and self-flagellation like
it's no good unless I stay up all night
and I'm exhausted when I'm done you know
I can't get that satisfaction unless I
know you know I'm bleeding out of my
eyeballs by the time it's completed and
that's no good that's no good and that's
you know that's just an extreme form of
I mean
people who do extreme things do extreme
things and they'll they engage in all
sorts of extreme behaviors is what we
find and so that's just going to be a
normal part of your personality that's
what we find and so you're into a wreck
guard rails for sure absolutely you know
we have to we have to manage ourselves
we either either we manage our feelings
or they're going to manage us that's the
bottom line that's actually one of the
key points of this book is emotional
self-management is the whole idea that
you can through metacognition understand
the nature of your urges and desires and
emotions and their practices protocols
you can put in your place in your life
to put space between your your impulses
and your reactions you can be the
manager your prefrontal cortex can
govern your limbic system because you
choose your reactions if you actually
know how it's done so there's a whole
bunch of very practical lessons on how
to do that um I want to get deeper into
metacognition but let's put a pin on
that for now and just stick with getting
through these these uh the three macros
here so the final one is purpose yeah
well before we get to that by the way
there is this is this problem of not
being able to keep any satisfaction that
is always seemed like the tyranny of
life like you know if when I moved to
California it's going to be so great
because it's going to be so Sunny
forever and after six months I was just
as depressed as I were I was but the
taxes are forever you know it's or the
new car smell wears off or you know I
thought that I was going to love having
that house and now it's just a house but
there is a way to defeat that it's just
a very unnatural feeling thing to do
which is instead of adding instead of
this this notion that the satisfaction
comes from more more what's your secret
more is to remember that this real
satisfaction can be thought of can be
modeled as all of your halves divided by
your wants
halves divided by wants now we know that
to increase the satisfaction you can
increase the numerator have more yeah
but it's even more efficient to want
less to decrease the denominator the
fastest way for you to get lasting and
stable satisfaction sort of a blood
sugar level that's not all over the
place is to manage your wants is to want
less I had literally have an exercise
that I take my students through that I
practice myself on my birthday I used to
have a bucket list and the bucket list
is you know your all your Ambitions and
desires and you imagine yourself
enjoying all these wonderful things I
now have a reverse bucket list where I
take all of my ambitions and desires and
worldly stuff you know money and you
know success and I might get it or I
might not but I cross out the attachment
so it's no longer a ghost in my head in
my limbic system governing me I make the
decision using my executive capacity
that I will no longer be governed by
that and it absolutely works the reverse
bucket list is an incredibly effective
way metacognitively for you to manage
these desires and in so doing your
satisfaction lasts it's more enduring
it's it satiates it it's less well yeah
I guess I guess I'll feel better if I
buy something on the Internet you know I
guess I'll feel that your your fall prey
much much less to that so I wind up
talking a lot about
wanting less as opposed to having more
that requires a jiu jitsu black belt
level of discipline and uh and
determination like overcoming your
default settings around desire and wants
uh it doesn't come it doesn't come down
here naturally but once you're thinking
about it you will do it this is the key
is being conscious being awake well this
is the metacognition why don't we just
talk about it now I mean basically you
know metacognition is this means of of
managing your emotions self-regulating
right
um having enough presence of mind uh and
awareness to understand what's occurring
emotionally within you as a result of
generally some external stimulation
right and and and being able to gauge it
and have that extra moment and choose an
appropriate and better more adaptive
emotional response to that scenario
rather than reflexively reacting that's
right and you know when when your kids
were little and they were screaming
their heads off because you didn't cut
the sandwich vertical or horizontally
you cut it you know diagonally or
something and and they were yelling and
you said use your words
that what you were telling them was to
become metacognitive to be conscious of
their feelings and to articulate those
feelings you were asking them to move
the experience of their distress into
their prefrontal cortex of your brain so
that the limbic system is very ancient
and its whole job is delivering feelings
to your to your your prefrontal cortex
so you can decide what to do with them
so you can decide whether or not you
know flip off the driver who almost hit
you or whatever it happens to be but you
know the the the the emotions the
reactions their innate coming from the
limbic system to keep you alive
the problem is that little kids don't
can't make that connection and a lot of
adults don't either you see that you
know when somebody is reactive a really
reactive person they have an emotion
they spill the emotion they think
something's funny they laugh they think
something is stupid they yell whatever
it happens people with bad tempers they
tend to be really reactive they can get
much better at not being reactive they
can be less limbic and the way to do
that is putting more space between
stimulus and response there's basically
three three techniques for doing that
for how to be less governed by your
feelings number one what they all
require by the way is more time between
what you feel and what you do is getting
better at putting time and you know so
your grandmother you know Grandma roll
probably said Rich Richie when you feel
angry count to ten something like that
right the truth is that the data are
very clear that she was mostly right but
it takes about 30 seconds the best way
when you're angry or you're about to say
something and you're about to erect the
next 48 hours of your marriage by what
you're about to say is stop and for
count to 30 and imagine the consequences
of saying what first came to your mind
which was the limbic thing that you were
about to say that gives the experience
time to be registered in the prefrontal
cortex and you can have a better
reaction you can choose a better
reaction that's number one choose a
better reaction number two is to choose
a better emotion you can actually choose
a better emotion that's also appropriate
to the circumstances but it has to be
chosen in the prefrontal cortex and the
last is to disregard the emotion and
simply observe the situation these are
three very strong techniques that are
backed up in the literature but they all
require that we take simply time between
what we feel and how we react there's
there's what that looks like on paper
and then there's what that looks like in
practice right we all know what it's
like to be in a supercharged emotional
state right we're not
in control of our
um best reactive self in that scenario
it's only in the aftermath where we're
able to kind of realize what we have
just said or done right um so buying
that sliver of additional time
is is challenging you know because
you're being asked to do it in the very
state of mind and being in which it's
most difficult to access I know and
that's called amygdala hijacked by the
way the amygdala is the part of the
limbic system of the brain most
associated with fear and anger and it
just lights up so you know when the a
car almost runs you over
um and you're a pedestrian the sidewalk
and the car almost hits you that crosses
your visual cortex passes down the
retinal nerve and is as is uh is is
actually registers in the occipital load
of your brain as a large Predator so
what that does is sends a signal to your
amygdala just lights up the amygdala
that says alarm you're about to be eaten
by this enormous Predator attacked by
this enormous Predator that sends a
signal through the through the
hypothalamus of the brain to the the
pituitary glands then down to the
adrenal glands you have your kidneys
spitting out stress hormones all in 74
milliseconds that thing goes down in
seventy four one thousandths of a second
you're three to four seconds behind in
your prefrontal cortex and what you're
going to do you know you've already
flipped off the driver and and you're
you're shaking and sweating before you
even know what has happened and you're
and your amygdala your limbic system has
just saved your life that's the bottom
line and how important that is that's
why all of this takes practice and here
these are good ways to practice this as
a matter of fact so if there's a lot of
people watching us have a bad temper I
don't have a big temper problem I have
other problems but I don't have a big
temper problem anybody who has a big
temper problem and it's it's hurting
their relationships let's say you're in
a you're married or you have a
girlfriend and you're snapping at her
and it's not right say I'm going to make
a decision that when I'm I start to get
hot I'm going to say to her
I'm trying to work on my temper and so
what I want to do is I just want to I
want to sort of take it down a notch I
want to I want to sit down here for a
second and I want to pick up the
conversation here in a minute is that
okay and and your wife will be like
would you like convert to a new religion
or you know are you on some sort of a
psychiatric medication and it works
wonders by actually declaring that
declaring that you're putting time
between your limbic system and your
prefrontal cortex and and having people
assist you in that who actually have
your mental well-being your emotional
well-being um front and center in their
lives too
yeah that was that would be an extreme
example like having a a really hair
trigger temper right everybody knows
that that's not good and wishes they
could behave otherwise if that's
something that you succumb to but
there's
so many permutations of that like what
about yeah I generally you know when I
get an email like that I kind of avoid
responding to it or what it's I think I
guess what I'm getting at is
the is the first step not simply to
develop a greater self-awareness of your
behaviors and where they Lead You astray
like when your default responds to a
certain scenario
generally gets you a sub-optimal you
know kind of results to an inventory of
that try to figure out what the contrary
action is in that scenario so I think
first like writing all writing down like
all of these different ways in which you
wish you could like respond to
situations better so that you have a
framework or a blueprint or a map of so
when those scenarios come up a little
light bulb goes off and say for sure it
says here's an opportunity yeah and this
is one of the reasons that you know
metacognition requires certain sets of
practices and protocols in your life so
you know I recommend you know meditation
where you're meditating on one of the
things that people typically do in in
centered meditation practices is to say
you're sitting in meditation you're
saying rich is angry today you're
looking at yourself almost third person
that's a hugely metacognitive thing to
do to understand yourself better give
yourself more time and move experiences
into the prefrontal cortex prayer is
another way to do that to actually just
to say to the Divine help me with this
thing that I'm feeling busy or
articulating it journaling is incredibly
effective because once you write
something down you're activating the
prefrontal cortex as opposed to just the
limbic systems no longer a Phantasm
walking in nature can be incredibly
helpful because what you're doing is
you're you're you're you're giving
yourself time and space to be thinking
about these issues for some people
therapy is really helpful but therapy is
only really helpful when it helps you
understand yourself better when it gives
you a better repertoire and and set of
techniques with these feelings what
cognitive behavioral therapy can be so
incredibly effective because it's
basically you know applied metacognition
yeah
meditation has been crucial for me in
this context for that very reason of
buying me time yeah with that level of
awareness even if it's just just one
more millisecond you know it's a very
imperfect thing because you know listen
you're not going to be able to do 100
push-ups if you've never done a push-up
before you're going to fail most of the
time but I think being persistent in
this Pursuit is is really a worthy one
and the other thing that I've realized
through consistent meditation is the
reduced half-life of the intense
negative emotional response so even if
you are experiencing anger to use your
example it's not going to persist as
long that's right because your awareness
around it and the mindful approach that
you're bringing to it
that alone tends to disintegrate it much
more rapidly well once something once a
a basic negative emotion or basic
positive emotion for that matter and
there aren't that many I mean the basic
positive emotions are joy and interest
and the basic negative emotions are
discussed and sadness and fear and anger
and there aren't there's complex
emotions that are a cocktail of these
things to be sure which is why we have
such a very emotional repertoire but
when these these basic emotions are
experienced in the prefrontal cortex
they're a lot less scary
they're a lot less serious they make a
lot less sense in a lot of cases because
you're looking at it as if you were
looking at somebody else's anger it's
funny because you know when you you know
if you came to me and you said you have
this particular problem and you told me
about the problem I would be I wouldn't
be freaking out I wouldn't freak out
about your problem I would be looking at
it analytically and giving you some
advice and almost certainly I would
think it's less of a problem than you do
I have this very interesting experience
one time that I always remember about
this so
um when I was one it was in Washington
DC I was running this fancy think tank
in DC with you know hundreds of people
and millions of dollars and it's right
at the center of a lot of political
controversies and and my life was very
stressful in many periods and everything
was like Defcon five everything was a
big fire all the time and something was
going down and then and some bad story
was coming out in the Press about me it
was very unflattering and and it
actually sort of is sort of Illustrated
that I can't exactly remember what the
Scandal was at this point but you know
10 or 15 years ago and and I was just I
was losing sleep I was just losing my
mind about this and I come home and my
wife says Esther says there's a guy a
good friend who lived right across the
street our kids all played together he
was a super high-powered lawyer like a
mega high-powered lawyer that was in the
middle of bad nonsense companies getting
a big trouble just why don't you go talk
to it why don't you go talk to him see
what he thinks about this he's not in
your business he's not in politics it's
okay so I go knocking and says hey and
and I said you've been reading the
papers about this thing he says oh yeah
I saw that thing that's going on with
you huh I said can I ask your advice and
so we sit down in his dad it's like The
Godfather you know it says mahogany Den
dimmed lights and all this and and I
told him what's going on and I said
how big is a problem is this he said you
know problems can be ranged on a scale
of seriousness and all the years that
I've been practicing law where zero is
not a problem and 10 is the biggest
problem I've ever seen
your problem is a 0.25 hmm
and he meant it he really really meant
it to me it felt like a 9.75
and this is what your limbic system will
do to you when you're too limbic now I
don't I wish I didn't need him but it
was incredibly helpful to me in my
prefrontal cortex especially aided with
with the techniques of prayer and
meditation and the things that I'm very
involved in in my life it helps me see
that 0.25 says 0.25 9.25 so in other
words the limbic system isn't so great
at grading threats a threat is the
threat is a threat and you're going to
have that response to it whether it's a
0.25 totally I mean it's a bad tweet
yeah feels like a saber-toothed tiger
that's the reason that we're so
maladapted to Modern Life
every athlete I know is going to tell
you that having the right gear is key to
Performance if what you're wearing is
poorly crafted it's just going to put
distance between you and those goals
you've set you owe it to yourself to
invest in the best and the best is on
I'm obsessed with the cloud Ultra right
on the trails and I just got the new
next-gen Cloud Stratus 3 for the road
I'm loving those but on also has this
incredible line of lightweight high
performance apparel that it's just
beyond anything I've previously donned
it's like this second to none Second
Skin I love to rock the sweat wicking
Ultra tee and the ultra shorts which
have this pocket right at the base of
the spine that perfectly anchors your
phone no jiggle I'm just so proud to
partner with on and I love their vision
for the future where their gear is
fossil free and engineered for
circularity
so check out their amazing lineup of
super comfortable sleek and durable
pieces for yourself on.com
you know our last conversation that we
had here like has really stayed with me
and has and and you know the the books
and the work that you do because I I do
you know when you're on somebody else's
show I always listen
um it really uh has
taken up residence in in my
Consciousness in a good way and I have
slowly but surely made some changes like
yesterday I had a ton of work I was
anxious I was feeling overwhelmed
um but my mother-in-law who's 93 is in
an assisted living facility not not far
from here and Julie was like let's go
see my mom who was completely
inconvenient for me but you know she's
not going to be around much longer and
my two youngest ones are about to leave
home for school this is the final week
that I get to spend time with them and I
was like yeah I need to go yeah right
and I think what I'm getting at is that
and this goes to the practices and the
kind of way of being and the the way of
doing that you express in the new book
is that you have to cultivate these new
habits and these habits are
uncomfortable like every fiber in my
being is like no I need to stay here I
have to I have to be prepared for Arthur
I'm not quite ready yet right so to do
something to take that contrary action
doesn't feel like the right thing to do
often yeah until you repeat it and then
it becomes like a new neural pathway
exactly right and you know that you're
you're an old hand at doing stuff like
that I mean that if it just if it feels
good do it you sit on the couch you eat
sweets all day yeah you have another
beer that's what you do if you're
following the path of least resistance
if you're following Mother Nature's
imperatives which is to to do things
that make you feel comfortable and
survive another day and maybe even pass
on your genes you're going to do a lot
of things they're not good for you you
know you have to understand the animal
path for sure and the animal path exists
for all sorts of good reasons but we
have choices as well we can make choices
that help us lead a better life a Divine
path if you will and that's not even a
religious concept necessarily it's the
idea of doing something better because
we have the capacity and free will to
make these decisions but you have to
know what those those urges are you have
to be in touch with what those Cravings
are you have to do something hard on
purpose you have to embrace the fact
that it's incredibly uncomfortable I
have to tell you you're super endurance
athlete this is completely unnatural and
very beautiful at the same time there's
a version of that super endurance
mentality and the whole way that we can
live our lives yeah I'm not afraid to
put myself in uncomfortable situations
but I have my preferences around what
those uncomfortable situations are uh
you know I choose the the uncomfortable
situations that everyone else thinks are
hard but actually are second nature to
me and the real uncomfortable situations
are are more the emotional and mental
ones that are contrary to this narrative
that I I've told myself repeated over
decades that this is who I am this is
what I do if you want to make your way
in the world you do X Y and Z and two
kind of push that aside and say actually
I'm going to do this other thing that
feels totally wrong right but I know
because I've done the work and I've read
your books and I've listened to you and
I have other sources of influence in my
life that help guide my decision making
process
um to make that uh decision that doesn't
quite feel right in recovery it's called
contrary action you know we do the
opposite of what your gut is telling you
to do yeah all the decisions that you
made ended you up in these rooms maybe
you should reassess it's called the oss
the opposite signal strategy in among
social scientists and there are lots of
cases for example where if you're very
lonely a classic case of this is when
people are lonely it impairs their
executive function the one thing that
you really need to do when you're
feeling lonely is to get out of the
house is to call a friend is to get
Sunshine is to get outside but what
you're because of the impairment of your
executive function due to the actual
loneliness what you do is you curl up in
a blanket and watch Netflix and eat
Haagen-Dazs yeah and so you have to use
the opposite signal strategy you can get
very good at the opposite signal
strategy you know there's one little
Wrinkle In This which is for somebody
who's a discipline freak you know
somebody who broke out of the shackles
or something really bad like addiction
the problem with that is that you can
you can and turn your life into kind of
a discipline Factory that's dedicated
toward the success toward being special
toward being being unusual toward the
discipline itself and that becomes a
dangerous path yeah in and of itself and
you know one of the things that I find
and you know I've I've found this again
and again you know when the last time we
we talked I was talking about my book
from strength to strength which was I
was talking to extraordinary performers
all over the world and and the
unhappiness that they feel when when
they're dedicated entirely to their
Superior performance as opposed to being
happy people with happy lives that they
have dedicated themselves to being
special at the expense of being happy
and that's the problem so if you're
saying I who's who's ritual ritual is a
hard worker ritual is super dedicated
ritual is excellent and that means I
work and I work and I work and
you actually have to dedicate yourself
to being Fully Alive as a person meaning
you got to go see your mother-in-law
who's 93 and spend some time with your
kids because specialness and happiness
can be at odds with each other right
that's a threat to specialness you know
I found myself thinking and I've said it
out loud uh in the past this idea that
I'm okay with not being I I I I'm I'm
fine with not being happy I'll double
down on special yep I'll be a martyr
I'll work really hard I'll provide for
my kids and and try to set them up for
the best life that they can possibly
have I'll do this thing in the studio
until I just bleed out of my eyeballs
right and my happiness is a luxury
um that I don't necessarily need it's
sort of a form of hubris too because
yeah it's masochistic and narcissistic
yeah any loser can be and be happy but
not everybody can be special and there's
a lot there's a lot of evolution that
goes into that too because Mother Nature
does not actually care If You're Happy
Mother Nature has only two goals for
Rich and Arthur and everybody watching
us which is survival and passing on your
genes that's all Mother Nature cares
about and so if you actually find a
really good way to survive and pass on
your jeans you're going to hit the
button and hit the button and you're
going to become miserable doing that
until you break free and choose the
Divine path or the animal path until you
actually choose to do something that is
that mother nature is not urging you to
do and and that's the secret
yeah I said my two youngest are are
going away to school we won't be fully
empty nesters but pretty close to it
which means my wife and I are entering a
new phase of our relationship we've been
together 23 years
um and as you know when you're raising
kids
things can become
not necessarily transactional but
logistical right it's all about who's
going where and who needs to be where
and what's happening it's day planning
you know relentlessly for many many
years and then suddenly when you don't
have to do that yeah who are you I said
you know we said for For Better or For
Worse but not for lunch
and uh yeah no it's actually an
interesting thing because couples they
get together because they they they find
each other interesting fascinating
attractive wonderful but then after a
while especially after they have kids a
bunch of kids and the kids grow up the
one thing they still have in common is
the kids and then they lose that and
they have nothing in common and they
have to reacquaint themselves with each
other they have to start dating again I
wind up doing a lot of work on the
happiness of relationships and the even
the Neuroscience of of of romantic love
for people who've been married for a
really long time and it's an interesting
subject I have to say and it's not
self-evident how it works what is what
is the big reveal there I mean I know
that at the heart of it it's really
about companionship and friendship like
are you with your best friend right and
it's not so much about differences or
similarities in fact the difference is
um can be a beautiful and and perhaps
necessary piece in in making that puzzle
fit together well you're you're you know
you're incredibly observant because one
of the things I talk an awful lot about
in this new book about the fact that the
big mistakes that we make for example is
thinking that uh the the core of a
permanent romantic relationship is
Passion it's actually companion at love
it really is figuring out a way to have
a companion relationship which also can
have plenty of passion in in terms of
people who are romantically involved
will for your with your spouse for
example but the uh but the other point
is that you you as you grow together you
you change together and you find ways to
change together you're looking for ways
to actually change together to do new
things together in ways that you weren't
able to and so I recommend that when
when when kids leave home the couples
say what's all the stuff that we we
always said we wanted to do but we never
did it and that we're still not doing
you know and for me and my wife when we
became empty nesters definitively two
years ago I mean the kids are they're
not off the payroll but they're not
coming I don't think they're they're
coming back is um we always said we wish
that we could you know spend a month at
the beach in the summer and a month in
the beach in in the in the winter and
and go away one weekend a year together
and one weekend a month together I
should say and and it would but then the
kids left we didn't do it and said you
know what we can we can afford to do it
we're very fortunate in that way and we
have places that we can go so we're
doing it we're going away one weekend a
month and we're spending a you know a
month in California and in the winter
time and a month on the beach in
Massachusetts in the summertime it costs
money and all that but it's really good
for our marriage I have to say and we're
just saying
like thank God there's aren't other
people you know hanging around here
I
yeah there's a part of it like this is
awesome like I don't have to worry about
where somebody is and pick them up or
yeah what they're doing at home they're
taking care of that part's exciting the
other part
um there's a little bit of fear but but
turning that fear into opportunity I
think is is where the the magic yeah
yeah we we also and I'm sure you do this
with your wife too
my wife and I were on a spiritual
journey together you know we did the the
Camino the community in Santiago but
we're both you know we're both very
interested and we're Catholic and and
she's she's actually a graduate student
in Theology and so she reads to me a lot
and she teaches me a lot things I had no
idea and it's pretty mind-blowing I have
to say to be to be you know living with
a theology Professor you know somebody
who's doing this really really deep work
and taking me on this on this particular
Journey
um plus you know the fact is that her
Spanish accent is kind of has a narcotic
effect on me the problem I have is
staying awake when she talks because
it's just it leads me into you know this
Bliss I'm a bad sleeper that's that's
cool um I want to get I want to work our
way back to the face piece in the
context of a broader conversation around
happiness but let's let's frame this in
the context of the new book you've got
this incredible book that's about to
come out it'll be out when this podcast
goes up build a life you want that you
co-wrote with Oprah I want to hear all
about that but what's really great about
this book building upon your your last
book strength to strength which was
really about finding meaning as we age
up and you know different forms of
intelligence this is my crystallized
intelligence beard yeah it looks good
this is really about the Art and Science
of happiness and what you've done
brilliantly is really canonize this
elusive confusing field of understanding
what is happiness what is it what isn't
it right
um and and and layering in like the
science that supports these ideas around
happiness and not necessarily how to get
it but how to cultivate more of it in
your life through
uh strategies for how you approach your
thinking and your decision making
Etc so let's just start at the beginning
like how did this book come together how
did it happen with Oprah I mean this is
like an amazing opportunity it is and it
was her idea so what happened was during
the during the coronavirus epidemic and
everybody was locked down and you know
burrowed in for that she was re she's a
reader of my column in the Atlantic so
Thursday mornings every Thursday morning
in the Atlantic I have 1500 words on the
science of happiness and I don't I don't
know who reads it I know it's half a
million people a week are reading the
thing and who it could be anybody turns
out Oprah Winfrey was reading it and and
following it and she read from strength
to strength and and called they called
you know this is Oprah Winfrey and I'm
like yeah this is Batman I mean you know
it's it's and and but it was and and I
did her podcast and we talked about it
it was like a house on fire no we see
the world much the same way different
background I mean she was in mass media
and and I came at it from a more
academic perspective and I'm a teacher
but we have the same goal goal you know
lift people up bring people together in
bonds of happiness and love using ideas
and and you know we were we did a couple
of these media things together and it
was really great it was a real
synchronicity it was a Harmony between
us and and I was out here in California
and I was having dinner with her and she
said you know
if I still had my show she said I would
have had you on 30 times and and that
would have really launched it into the
public Zeitgeist you know this work that
this where the world is the classroom on
the science of happiness and everybody's
hobby can be the science of happiness
and and it's beneficial to have that be
their hobby but I don't know the show
anymore so why don't we write a book
together where I'm talking around the
ideas and introducing the ideas and then
you're filling in the gaps on the
science and the Neuroscience because
it's about 30 Neuroscience about 50
um uh social science which is my
background in about 20 philosophy but
it's all applied and it's all it's
supposed to be something that people can
read and we started on this project and
she just guided it expertly pushing it
back in One Direction she came up with
the title of the book it was her idea
for the title and and you know her
narrative weaves in and out of the in in
the book in a way that's really going to
appeal to an audience that I never would
have thought of before so it was a very
beautiful experience we cooked up the
whole structure of the book in her tea
house in Montecito in California and I'm
thinking you know it's like I'm just
this small town college professor who
fell off the turnip truck in front of
Oprah's Tea House you just never know
what life is gonna bring right but then
does your uh hey let Let's uh let's
spend a month on the beach with your
wife turn into yeah we're spending a
month on the beach but I'm gonna be
writing this book
yeah yeah no I mean it's a good point
Rich so I was writing the book over over
the holidays you know in Christmas time
in 2022 and we were in San Clemente
where we had a house and uh um you know
I have a son who lives in San Clemente
because he's a Marine based on Camp
Pendleton exactly
um and you know during the day I would
work and I had a desk and I was looking
at a Pacific Ocean you know writing this
book and writing writing writing sending
chapters and things to Oprah and and
going back and forth but I was really
enjoying it in a different way by
getting out of my typical ecosystem and
I wasn't teaching during that period and
it was a beautiful experience I have to
say and uh I mean he to be frank
vacation is not the easiest thing for me
it's always been uh it's always been
I've always white knuckled my vacations
because stopping is hard getting the
machine off is hard you can relate to
that right
um but it's all it's also good for me to
make an effort to do that I've been on
vacation since just two days ago before
we're taping this podcast as a matter of
fact and and in Massachusetts near the
cape and that's been really great yeah
with my new grandson oh that's right
amazing yeah with respect to these
negative emotions I'm thinking about
uh guilt
shame
Envy that's a big thing that you talk
about in the book
um what are the function or the purpose
of these emotions and how should we how
should we think about them I mean a big
kind of
overarching theme of the book is
um the
the process of engendering your life
with more happiness doesn't involve the
the denial of unhappiness in your life
like we experience the full panoply of
emotions and we need to feel the feels
right
um
so where do emotions like that come in
where are they counterproductive and how
do we process them in a healthy way so
these are all complex emotions they're
largely complex negative emotions that
we feel and and evolution has delivered
them to us in response to our need to
survive and pass on our genes and one of
the for example Envy is a way that we we
understand ourselves in the context of
other people so that we'll have a Spur
to get better and rise in the hierarchy
and pass on our genes that's how you
could that's how an evolutionary
psychologist would would explain the
phenomenon of Envy it's incredibly
maladapted to Modern Life you know we're
envious of you could be envious of
somebody because they have you know a
million more downloads of their podcast
per month which doesn't really affect
you but it makes you feel a little bit
less perhaps you know I'm sure you don't
feel that but some some people do if
we're trivial things you know that we
all because we we understand ourselves
as a little bit less and we have an
evolutionary imperative feel or not feel
ourselves as less because we don't want
to because that means getting eaten or
left behind or cast out of the tribe or
not mating in ancient times it doesn't
mean these things right now because you
don't want 75 kids you actually want
your wife to love you and she doesn't
care how many downloads of of the
podcast there are so the result is we
need to manage those things very very
aggressively and the way to deal with
these things these maladapted
evolutionary impulses that we have is
almost always through metacognition
choosing a better acknowledging them and
choosing a better emotion so the case of
Envy is a classic is a classic one
there's two kinds of Envy there's
malignant envy and benign Envy benign
Envy is where you envy somebody who
really is meritorious you know an
astronaut you say I just Envy what that
guy's been able to do with his life you
don't want less for him because it's not
more like admiration it has admiration
in it it's Envy but also has admiration
in it and then there's malign or
malicious or malignant Envy where you
you envy something that somebody has and
you don't feel like they deserve it and
you want the worst for them and that
really brings out the worst in you
that's something that's really super
damaging to envy people in a malicious
way and that's very very common that's
the reason that you're able to sell
magazines about the you know the
scandals and problems of of celebrities
and rich people that's all because of
this particular Envy it's normal to feel
these things and so the way to cope with
it is to look to acknowledge it
understand why you feel these things
acknowledge that you wish that there
were better things in your life and
you're willing to work for them and then
make a substitute emotion make a blessed
emotion and in the case of Envy that's
admiration
what is going on
in terms of the neurochemistry of
something like schadenfreude like this
idea that people are deriving some kind
of perverse pleasure out of you know the
misfortunes of of somebody else that's
just pure Spite and that's that's what
comes from malicious Envy that's that's
uh unmanaged malicious Envy Lisa
schadenfreude it's incredibly dangerous
for people who feel it it's I mean again
it's not a good thing it's you know most
religions think it's a sin
um but but the real problem no matter
what your religion or lack thereof is is
extremely damaging to you emotionally to
to feel shot and freuda to it's
interesting because you'll you'll have
all these cases all these studies that
show that when people feel it that they
enjoy the the the the the the to imagine
doing harm or harm coming to a
particular person and that's doing the
same thing it's actually doing the same
kind of psychological damage to you as
if you were a party to actual violence
it's not doing the violence to that
person thank God but it's doing the same
damage to you as somebody who's party to
that violence right and that's something
that we really need to manage if we're
going to become more human but actually
more effective and happier what about
guilt and shame does it work the same
way uh yeah shame and guilt are slightly
different phenomena of course and they
actually have a productive aspect to
them I mean no I know it's modern to say
you shouldn't ever feel any shame for
anything but you should you know if you
commit an immoral act that hurts
somebody you should feel ashamed for it
because you need to learn your lesson
and the immediate penalty to you even if
it's
not something that you're going to pay
an overt penalty you know a fine to the
government or or you know shaming on
social media or cancellation or
something but just that you did
something wrong is that you feel a
little bit bad about yourself and that's
good that pain is actually good because
pain is a signal pain is a pain in our
lives is a is a is is an alarm it's a
lesson that we need to get and a lot of
times you have physical pain for example
it exists for a particular reason
physical pain itself is an incredibly
interesting phenomenon it has two parts
to it so I know that you're you know
you're always dealing with back issues
right because of all the strain and
stress that you put yourself under over
the years
um the there there's the sensory
component of pain which occurs you know
it feels like the sight of where you
hurt yourself it's actually your brain
of course but that's you know has nerve
implication and then there's the
affective component of pain which is the
I hate this part of the pain that part
is really interesting because that uses
a part of the brain called the dorsal
anterior cingulate cortex and that's the
same part of the brain that's used for
the the affective component of physical
pain and the effective component of
emotional pain the same part of the
brain is actually lighting up when you
stub your toe is when your girlfriend
breaks up with you that's incredibly
important to understand because pain is
pain is pain and that's a signal that is
time to do something different the
dorsal anterior cingulate cortex is baby
that toe don't do that deadlift
you shouldn't be in that relationship in
the first place something's wrong here
and you need to actually make some
changes you got to listen to that you
shouldn't numb that that's a you know
the problem with that's really what
opioids are are are they're they're
calming down the dorsal anterior
cingulate cortex so you don't feel the
affective component of pain and the
result of that is you'll just ruin your
life by doing the things that are
painful right yeah if you're muted out
all of that signaling then your
antenna's broken and you're not able to
course correct when you're
doing things exactly right they're
exactly right you know numbing yourself
is an incredibly now you might want to
take an analgesic to blunt it right oh
one note
um the the sensory component of pain is
better with anti-inflammatories like
agile
the affective component of pain is dealt
with with acetaminophen Tylenol Tylenol
what it really does is it calms down the
dorsal anterior cingulate cortex not so
you feel less pain but you care less
about the pain which is a really
interesting thing super interesting I've
never heard that and there's one study
that actually takes people who have
suffered from like a painful romantic
breakup and a course of Tylenol lowers
their mental pain over a three-week
period oh that's fascinating
[Laughter]
what's the Tylenol addicts yeah it's
like you've got to be careful don't take
beyond the recommended dosage on the
package we all know people who who
just seem genetically wired for
happiness there certainly is a genetic
component to happiness this book is
really about the non-genetic aspect of
of of of bringing more happiness into
your life but people fall anywhere along
that spectrum of happy versus unhappy in
terms of their just Baseline disposition
yeah that's right so about 50 of your
basic disposition is genetic
your mother literally made you unhappy
rich or happy I don't know how many
hours do you have right is your mom
watching
no no way right yeah
um so and we know that from identical
twin studies so identical twins are
separated birth and adopted into
separate families and there was it was
it was not a social science experiment
that would be horribly having all but
between you know the mid 30s and 1960s
there's a bunch of these that happened
and they were a number of them were
located and reunited and given
personality tests as adults and it turns
out that between 40 and 80 percent of
almost every personality characteristic
is genetic on the basis of seeing that
they have identical DNA but different
environments so that that's that a lot
of the stuff is going to University of
Minnesota very interesting studies and
somewhere between you know 44 and and
low 50 percent happiness so it's rounded
off to half of your happiness that's
your Baseline the moods you always go
back to so it's not happiness in a
cosmic sense of of of enjoyment plus
satisfaction plus purpose it's the moods
that you feel the disposition of pause
positive versus negative emotions now on
top of that you find people who are
because of their genetics and also
because of their circumstances and
habits that they have they feel positive
and negative emotions at different
levels and that's where it gets really
interesting this is something I didn't
know for and couldn't quite deal with
for the longest time there was a
scientist for many many decades believe
that happiness and unhappiness were
opposites that unhappiness meant a lack
of Happiness that's wrong happiness and
unhappiness are largely processed in
different hemispheres of the brain and
you can be unusually high in happy mood
and unusually high in unhappy mood that
means you're a high affect person or you
can be high low or low high or low low
and those are the four portraits of
people that people really need to
understand about themselves to manage
themselves appropriately so this is the
penis test this is the pannus test the
first the the positive affect negative
affect series that's in the book yes I
took the test oh what are you I'm uh I'm
squarely in the bad scientist category I
scored above average on both higher on
positive but definitely well above on
negative as well okay so that doesn't
surprise me a bit so let me explain
let's explain to the audience what that
what this is so high positive affect
which means you feel positive moods
intensely and express them intensely and
high negative that's high high or high
affect person that's called the mad
scientist that's a quarter of the
population
every this is this is a population of
people or a group of people that tends
to be into everything and have strong
opinions about everything everything is
great or it sucks there's almost there's
no there's no gradations in there and
you're really hard to be around because
like yeah yeah right it's really
difficult to be married to a mad
scientist it's a really difficult thing
because it's just you're just Moody is
the way and and your moods change is the
way that it works now I'm 90th
percentile and positive affect and I'm
88th percentile and negative affect wow
I'm imagining you know what the scores
are because I want to compare my scores
um it was I think it was 40 oh 41 on the
positive 95 percentile and positive and
27. pretty high so you're about 70th
percentile and negative and about 95th
percentile and positive so you're very
very high positive but you're way above
average and negative two but if I had
taken this test as I was taking it I was
thinking how set in stone is this
because 15 years ago if I took this test
I know that I would have been much lower
on the positive I don't know if I would
have been higher on negative but my life
is so much better now and I'm generally
much happier than I was then yeah for
sure so there's immutability to this
there's immutability to it based on
circumstance but your Baseline will be
the same so if under under the same life
circumstances you'd have the same
panelist profile probably but if you're
like in 15 years ago you weren't
drinking no no but life wasn't as good
as it was my guess is when you were
in the grips of addiction that was a lot
different it was a lot different but
yeah that was because of circumstance so
circumstance can change it but you're
always going to go back into the groove
where you are you need to accept it love
it use it complement other people to you
who have this in other words your
executive team of people who work with
you should complement you and should not
exacerbate these Tendencies you need
people who have a different profile
around you and we can talk about that in
a second so that's really important yeah
yeah what's interesting is knowing that
and then knowing what the profiles are
of the people in your family and the
people you work with creates a lattice
work for better communication because if
you understand those default settings
then you kind of know how people
function and you don't resent them
because they're different than you yeah
now what everybody wants to be is the
high positive low negative and that's
about 25 of the population too those are
cheerleaders
everybody wants to be a cheerleader but
it's their cheerleaders have and they're
fun to be around and they're really nice
and they're Pleasant and they always
have a good word the problem is that
they tend to be
undiscriminating about quality and they
have an incredibly bad time getting
getting negative information so they
tend to be bad CEOs they tend to be bad
Executives because they won't give bad
news and they won't accept bad news it's
just all good all the time well yeah and
you know it's like when you have a
cheerleader boss everybody's at a
cheerleader boss they're like you know
hey Rich you're doing a great job this
year this whole organization is doing
well because of you and you're like
that's great right here and then you
hear the boss in the in in the office
next door where that incompetent idiot
Works saying the same thing you know
it's like or you know and then a wino
out in the alley you know getting the
same you know bit of you're just doing
great and you're looking great you
realize that they just they're blowing
smoke at everybody so they have to you
if you're a cheerleader you have to
learn how to accept and give bad news
now the the interesting ones the hard
ones are The Poets and the judges The
Poets are high negative and low positive
and nobody wants to be a poet but the
world needs poets they tend to be really
creative they tend to be very
discriminating they tend to be
incredibly accurate in their assessments
we need poets in our companies is the
bottom line now they need to manage
themselves because they can be total
downers there's a way that this works
and and they suffer a lot but if they
can be paired up in a in a pair bond in
a good marriage with somebody who can
bring them up and couldn't understand
them and people who can appreciate their
the beauty that they can actually bring
to the world it's a it's a it can be a
really really good thing but that's a
difficult profile yeah what is the
optimal partner profile for the poet so
the op that you need somebody who has
high high positive effect but who
appreciates the poet and who's not going
to be driven Crazy by the fact that they
have low negative effects so low
positive affects so cheerleaders for
example they don't like poets but when
they can be married to and love and
appreciate poets that can be an optimal
pairing because they tend to fit each
other's gaps and what you find is the
most successful marriages are based on
complementarity and not on compatibility
the most successful marriages are not
compatible people they're complementary
people and the most complementary
profiles or a judge with a mad scientist
or or a poet with a cheerleader now it
doesn't always work out that way I'm
married do it I'm married to a bad
scientist I'm married to a Spanish bad
scientist imagine it's been we've been
married 32 years and it's been like 10
000 fights in my marriage yeah and the
reason is because mad scientists fight
with each other all the time part of the
reason is because man if you can if
you're going if you have a negative
negative moment it's like this bad
electricity that happens and especially
you know my wife's being Spanish
fighting is just another form of
communication right so right but when
the positive and the positive connect
then it's probably you know euphoric
Sublime yeah it can be just absolutely
Sublime but we have to understand each
other and I'm telling you this is an
example of how the knowledge is power
now the the judge is the low low these
are sober people these are judicious
people that's why it's called a Judge
Oprah's a judge Oprah's a judge and so
that's why Oprah and I work so well
together
you know I find her judgment absolutely
impeccable and she finds me highly
entertaining and the result is that we
can we can do this work and we just
enjoy it
you know she helps me I stay on the
rails
um and she likes the idea that we have
you know sort of high high amplitude of
ideas and creativity and electricity
when we're working together and so it's
a really really good match as it turns
out this feels like a much more astute
framework than calling someone uh you
know a toxic positive person or somebody
who's just a a downer or a pessimist
right this is a more nuanced well this
actually has some science behind it you
know yeah I mean the names themselves
don't come from the science I mean I
actually gave the names to it so the
people can remember what they are but
these The Pianist test is an incredibly
construct uh has construct validity in
other words it's been tested and tested
and tested and and passes all of the the
replication it's got a big literature
behind it how does this square with
people with a negativity bias are The
Poets the ones with the negativity bias
do we all have some form of negativity
bias yeah
what do we do with that well negativity
bias Keeps Us Alive
so um negativity bias means all it means
is you pay more attention to the
negative aspects of the thing of things
around you than the positive aspects and
the reason is because the positives are
nice to have but the negatives can be
lethal so when somebody's smiling at you
that's nice when somebody's frightening
at you you don't pay attention you can
die at least in ancient times now that's
horribly maladapted because if you're
walking around with negativity bias
saying everything sucks everything's bad
you can become incredibly unrealistic I
mean you and I have way more reason to
be optimistic than pessimistic in our
lives you know we have way more reason
to be grateful than resentful in our
lives but negativity bias will always
push you and if you tend to be either a
mad scientist or a poet
um you're gonna have a you have to
manage your the the outsized negativity
bias that this brings
so how does one manage that I certainly
have my bouts with it yeah consciousness
of this is really critically important
so remember the metacognition is
awareness of your emotions it's it's
it's it's thinking about thinking any of
these techniques is to say is to be
aware of these things that you're doing
because the problem is not that you that
we have unconstructive emotions is that
they're unmanaged all of our emotions
serve some sort of a purpose but
everything is worse when we don't manage
it that's what it comes down to so you
know you're a mad scientist which means
you're going to have outsized negative
uh affect at particular times in your
life and that's going to exacerbate the
negativity bias probably especially when
you're sleep deprived or you're hungry
or something like that that is gonna
that's gonna put your nerves on edge and
that's the time for you to say oh that
thing is happening and just start to the
reason Oprah and I wrote this book is so
people understand themselves better
That's the basis of self-management
that's the power that you can actually
get starts with knowledge it's amazing
how the Science Now validates or is
catching up to different strains of
thought philosophers religious
Traditions who sort of reverse
engineered this or just
back themselves into certain adaptive
strategies to deal with this in in 12
step this would be this would be halt
like when you're when you're having one
of those when you're having a negative
Moment Like halt hungry are you hungry
are you angry are you lonely are you
tired like if you're any of those things
or some combination of those things then
there's very easy fixes there's
behaviors you can do to kind of arrest
that negativity bias that's you know in
overdrive at the moment but one of the
things I'm curious about is and maybe
you can correct me I got the sense from
the book that
that that you're advocating for
replacing
a negative emotion with a more adaptive
emotion and I just know that I can't
think my way out of this scenario
because my brain created it like I can't
solve the problem with the same brain
that got me into it my only solution to
change my emotional relationship to
whatever is going on and and perhaps
inhabit a new emotional state is to take
an action right I have to so I have to
be action oriented it's not like I
should be positive here I'll have I'll
now oh I'm having a you know I'm having
this experience I need to feel this
other emotional I can't make myself feel
other than I feel right unless I
actually do something so for me it's
always about some kind of practical
thing that I can do like oh what or what
would a positive person do in this
scenario and try to model that yeah
that's the as if principle and it's a
very strong yeah yeah the the as if
principle is act the way you want to be
and you will become that person it runs
the causality in the in the opposite
direction it's a very famous paper
um there's a there's a body of work from
the late 19th century from a French
physiologist named duchenne and his
whole thing was mapping the human smile
he wanted to know if it was culturally
specific or or physiological based on
our common emotions we traveled all over
the world and he found 19 Smiles only
one is associated with true happiness
which he named after himself it's the
duchenne smiles like he discovered it
man so and it's in Papua New Guinea in
India and Japan United States and every
place else that that's that that's the
same smile every place
how do you know when somebody's actually
smiling it's purely physiological has
nothing to do with the mouth it's two
sets of muscles the zygomatic major
muscles in the upper cheeks and the
orbicularis oculi muscles in the corners
of the eyes when you see an old person
who has pronounced crow's feet that
means they've been doing the duchenne
smile a lot in their lives never get
BOTOX because you literally look like
you have not enjoyed your life as much
if you get rid of the crow's feet you
want crow's feet it's very attractive I
mean it doesn't make you look young but
it makes you look like an old happy
person okay now here's the interesting
question
if I am happy and then I do a duchenne
smile what if I were to do a duchenne
smile would it run the causality
backwards into my body and make me feel
happier and the answer is yes it it's
hard to do the way that you simulated
duchenne smiles to take a pencil
and put it horizontally in your molars
and bite down hard for 20 seconds that
stimulates the zygomatic major and
orbicularis oculi muscles just manually
and after 20 seconds you'll you'll
weirdly start feeling happier for like
an hour wow so that's an example of the
as if principle so what would a happy
person do what would a happier person do
what would a I'm feeling resentful what
would a grateful person do at this
particular one you're asking exactly the
right question and do that and then run
the sensation backwards and you'll get
that that's a William James the great
psychologist
um that really the founder of modern
social psychology
um he he's the one who first described
that if you want to feel something act
as if you did and tons of research since
since that is validated right right yeah
but it's interesting that so so the
emotional response as a result of a
behavior in other words like that right
the the mood shift the perception all of
that is in the Wake yeah well you're you
have an association between a behavior
and an emotion and so the association is
automatic it's pavlovian and so when you
usually when you have the the emotion
you you undertake the action
but they're so associated in your brain
that when you undertake the action
you'll feel the emotion as well right
it's a trick it's wild but it really
really works and so and there's also
things that you can do automatically get
into these habits so for example our
mutual friend Rayne Wilson he talks
about that that one of the things that
that comedians have in common is they're
often they suffer from depression a lot
of comedians are actually depressed one
of the reasons that they're so funny is
that when they feel sadness they make a
joke that's a that's a response that
they have it's a substitute emotion when
you feel sadness to actually make jokes
instead that and people who feel a lot
of sadness and have a lot of facility
for telling jokes they become Comedians
and that's why you see so many sad
clowns the poet is called the pup the
poet in the panest test because the
creative expression is the Adaptive
strategy to that that negative well it's
also the default the negative negative
emotion is so is so implicated in
creativity per se so I mean there's a
when you think of a poet you never think
of a laughing smiling poet you think of
some you know guy in a beret smoking a
filter of the cigarette looking bummed
that's what you think of that's the
thing that pops into your head there's a
reason for that neurophysiologically or
there's an association that suggests the
reason for that
so depression usually has rumination
involved rumination is iterative
thinking it's obsessive thinking about
something there's a part of the brain
called a ventral lateral prefrontal
cortex that's highly highly active when
we're ruminating ruminating ruminating
it's like what did I say I can't believe
I did that that's that's and very
implicated in people who are depressed
one of the things that you find is when
you up regulate serotonin it down
regulates the activity of the ventral
lateral prefrontal cortex it just makes
it easier to not ruminate which is
probably one of the ways that that
selective serotonin reuptake Inhibitors
like Prozac is one of the ways that it
probably alleviates depression symptoms
for many people but what you'll also
find is that that rumination is hugely
important for the creative process so
artists are are using the ventral
lateral prefrontal cortex and you find
that for example studies that show that
that when you have that big famous
artist Beethoven who is also a
depressive that when they had a bout of
depression it tended to coincide with
with hyperactive amounts of deep
creativity in the highest quality work
right that's what we find but this is
only fueling that idea that in order for
a creative depressant to do their best
work they have to just really foment
that depressive State yeah yeah you know
I know and yeah that that certainly
suggests that that's one of the ways
that and you know I've heard people who
will kind of put on errors and act more
bummed that they are so that they will
look more creative
the question is whether or not you would
you would actually choose a depressive
episode so you can get out another Act
of your Opera I actually don't know
anybody who would make that trade um but
there are there I I do think there I
know plenty of artists through uh the
recovery Community who are very afraid
of letting go of their you know
addictive Tendencies because yeah the
pain is the fuel for the output right
and if you heal that then you have
nothing left to say well they the part
of that is that they associate their
true Humanity with their pain look you
we feel the way that we feel about life
and you understand yourself in the
context of the feelings that you
experience and if your life is
predominantly one of pain yourself you
your richness is is implicated in all of
these feelings that you have and so the
problem is not that I won't be as good
at what I do the problem is I'm going to
lose myself
I I won't know who I am it's a it's a
death fear it's a loss of and and people
would prefer to be alive and in pain
than not alive at all and so there's
this kind of incoate
um Terror that people have of losing
themselves if all they've ever felt as
pain the association with me alive is me
in pain more broadly that gets to this
idea that our feelings Define us yeah
that our feelings you know as intense as
they are are the very substance of
identity right which in fact feelings
are just feelings and they're only as
powerful as we give them permission to
be and they're always changing right and
when you can become I just know in my
own case when I can become the Observer
of those feelings and create a little
bit of distance between myself and the
experience of those emotions they tend
to dissipate more quickly Oh yeah and
when people want when people actually
become better managers of their own
feelings they lose the fear they just
lose the fear and life just gets
manifestly better for everybody
so we didn't even get through all the
macros there's the third one oh the
heavy uh which is purpose yeah meaning
oh meaning meaning yeah I mean purpose
is actually a sub category of meaning so
it's almost a joke what's the meaning of
life you know you sit at the mouth of
the cave and ask the guru and the you
know the Himalayas what's the meaning of
life
and um that's that's a joke because it's
it's a question that is not meaningful
and so far as it's too General meaning
really has three parts to it it has the
three parts is defined by by
psychologists and philosophers are
coherence purpose and significance
coherence is the question
why do things happen the way they do
purpose is what's the arc and and goal
and direction of my life
and significance is does it matter if
I'm alive
and and when I dig into those particular
questions I can find a crisis of meaning
in people's lives it's a lot more
specific and we can deal with it better
I actually have a two-question
diagnostic test when I'm seeing people
have a crisis of meaning in their lives
if they don't have answers you want to
take the test sure all right heavy test
all right and there's no wrong answers
but you have to have answers okay so
here's the two questions
why are you alive
I am alive to uh
uh help other people
live better lives emotionally mentally
spiritually and physically solid
for what would you be willing to die
today
the welfare of my wife and children your
family
very solid
I believe those answers a lot of people
don't have answers
for what do you why are you alive I
don't know for what would you be willing
to die I don't know and the problem
there's a meaning crisis in your life
which is arguably the
most difficult and most complicated most
beautiful and and and sort of manifold
aspects of happiness because it involves
so much unhappiness you didn't find the
answers to the question you just gave me
except through tremendous pain you
didn't I mean if you know if you had not
gone through a lot in your life and
suffered you would know that you never
said you know what I found the meaning
of my life is that week at the beach in
Ibiza
that's not when you find meaning in your
life it's when you you you're you're
you're you get sick and you don't die
when you lose somebody when you're
rejected when you're afraid
that those are the moments when you
actually learn the answers to that and I
meet people all the time who are trying
to avoid unhappiness so much that they
never find meaning in their lives it's
like the object it's the opposite of the
hippie generation you know if it feels
good do it which is terrible advice even
worse is if it feels bad make it stop
if I'm in pain it means there's a
problem and I'm defective if there is
suffering I must treat it immediately
and make it go away that's folly because
that that's the way to avoid meaning and
if you avoid meaning you're not going to
find happiness yeah pain is the teacher
it is the guide that ultimately delivers
many a person to the promised land of
trying to understand greater meaning and
purpose in their lives six uh suffering
is incredibly sacred is it just you just
can't waste it all of the great answers
that I have sought throughout my life
have come through The Crucible of
suffering in vain and I've often thought
does it have to be that way no I know
for a lot of people they're able to
figure that out short of those
experiences but I'm also always very
careful to rob people of you know the
beauty of what can come when somebody is
enduring something challenging obviously
you don't want anyone you care about to
be suffering unnecessarily but there is
something Divine about that process that
makes me step aside and and and you know
just want to allow them to have that
process for themselves including your
kids yeah that's just horrible that's
the worst one but you know perfectly
that they need to suffer too because
they need to grow and they need meaning
and they deserve meaning and the idea
that we would take all of the suffering
out of their lives or protect them from
the vicissitudes the slings and arrows
of you know the things that happen to us
and don't do this and
it's not right it's not right because
you have to live a full existence
suffering will find them and trying to
deliver them from it all it will do is
spoil your relationship with them well
yeah there's a thing in the book where
you feel the question of like well you
know if I if I avoid suffering in you
know my life what you know how does that
work with happiness like don't worry
sufferings it'll find you like you're
not you're not avoiding suffering I
don't care you know what trajectory
you're on it'll hunt you down life has a
way it does and you know it's
interesting because when you see your
kids
I would ask my kids these questions why
are you alive what are you willing to
die
um it's probably not that fun to be
raised by a social scientist you know
but it's asked you before the podcast
like how are the kids doing with all
this stuff you're spouting all the time
are they rejecting it or are they
embracing it they embrace it implicitly
even though they roll their eyes when
it's like oh dad's gonna apparently do a
speech at dinner tonight you know it's
my dad was a mathematician so we would
also have math problems during dinner
but but it's interesting because you
know one of my kids I would make them I
had my kids write a business plan when
they were in high school
um because they're entrepreneurs I'm
sure that was fun yeah at the Enterprise
of life I mean they're startup
entrepreneurs that's the ultimate
Enterprises each person's life and um
and on VC so I get a business plan I
figure right if I'm gonna invest and and
so then I would send it back for
revisions and my son
um he hated school he just couldn't
focus and it didn't go well and all that
and his business plan was just I got
some college no this is unoriginal
what's how are you gonna find the
answers to these questions
right I've got my answers but I need the
answers your answer you have to find
your answers to these questions why am I
alive what I'm willing to die and he
finally he turned in this great business
plan that that said he was going to find
the answers by working with his hands
you know outside doing something real
and so he did he went to Grangeville
Idaho and he's working on a dry land
wheat farm for a couple Seasons After
High School then he joined the Marines
my son is in the Marines today's a scout
sniper in the Marine Corps which is a
scary job for being his mom yeah right
like but he has answers man I mean he's
23 years old he's married
and he has answers you know he's alive
because God made him and for what is he
willing to die his faith his family his
friends in the United States of America
oh
solid yeah he uh I I mentioned to you
beforehand he he he's he's born out of
time born out of time yeah he feels like
a great Generation guy Kinda Yeah and
he's a knucklehead you know I'm not
going to deny it I admire him so much I
admire him so much because he's found
the answer so much earlier than I did
you know I was I was doing my thing you
know I was 23 years old I was playing
the French horn I was traveling around I
was drinking too much doing my thing
um but I wasn't finding the answers it
took me longer to find those answers I
admire him so much because he and he did
he did a hard manly thing and he found
the answers to his questions and and
that's a really really good thing to do
how do you know when somebody has really
found those answers for themselves
genuinely and honestly as opposed to
making a a decision prematurely or for
the wrong reasons even if they believe
it to be true yeah that's a good
question and I'm sure that happens all
the time or they the question the
answers to the question is that they
should give right the noble answers
they're disconnected from who they are
they haven't really excavated the soul
they don't really know why they behave
the way that they behave and their
instincts are you know firing in ways
that they don't fully understand yeah
they're going to make decisions without
that level of of you know self-awareness
or mindfulness that's going to lock them
in on the right path that's right and
and the answer is that they have to be
the real answers that come after a
period of discernment and that requires
work the biggest mistake that a lot of
people I mean people come to me for
career advice all the time and you too
and I teach graduate students at Harvard
University and so they're you know
they're on a hardcore path toward
professional Excellence I mean mbas at
the Harvard Business School imagine this
you know these are going to be the
Masters of the Universe and and they're
incredibly excellent they're incredibly
smart but they have a lot of questions
about what they want to do
and the biggest mistake that they can
make is thinking that taking every
opportunity that comes into their path
or doing the thing that looks the most
worldly rewarding is actually going to
give them deliver them the answers to
their meaning questions and thus give
them a sense of purpose and then
happiness and that's just not right you
need to actually do the work and to do
the work you actually have to think
deeply about the answers to these
questions about the questions themselves
about you know who am I as a person and
so you know their every religious
tradition has a has the structure of
discernment you know the discernment of
spirits to Catholics Panna for the for
the for the Buddhists in the in the
Mahayana tradition sunnisis for the
ancient Greeks you know who am I what do
I stand for what do I mean I mean these
are the questions that that every
philosophical and religious tradition
has right people aren't going to HBS to
find answers to those questions although
until they think your classes over
subscribe so there is something about
that maybe they're they're they don't
know you know they don't know what
they're in for
um I would imagine that the the
population of students in your your
Harvard Business School class would skew
towards people who are motivated by
um Financial Security at the Kenneth are
you still teaching at the Kennedy I do
that population probably skews a little
bit more towards people who are
interested in power
or yeah public service or service yeah
service but um yeah it's a different
certainly it's a different group right
but you're you're you're you're dealing
with young people and and
and most likely I would imagine you tell
me I mean I think in general people when
they think about happiness they're
thinking about well I'll be happy when I
get this when I get the job when I get
the house when I get the promotion right
Etc or if you're asked and this is in
the book too like Oprah talks about like
well when people would ask her like or
she would ask people like what would
make you happy they would always have
some kind of answer that was really uh
uh a goal and not something that would
actually engender happiness in their
lives
um so
that sort of brings us to the four
pillars that you've arrived on that are
the true kind of drivers of of bringing
more of this into your life that that
are outside of that very very kind of
limited but but typical way of thinking
about right happiness that's right so
when people have inadequate emotional
self-management all the stuff we've been
talking about to this point they're
incredibly distracted all the time the
main problem that people don't make
proper Investments to get happier is
because they're so distracted I mean
life is basically a process of sitting
in an airport for a delayed flight and
so what are you doing instead of
shopping online and scrolling Instagram
and playing Solitaire and life is just
full of boring diversions because we're
so emotionally uncomfortable all the
time once you can emotionally
self-manage then you can focus on what
actually matters you can get the apps
off your phone maybe even literally and
you can focus on on investing in the
parts of your life that really will
bring more enduring happiness and what
those are is super validated by social
science I mean there's ten thousand you
could find you know is endurance going
to bring you more happiness than weight
training is you know is it you're going
to be happier as a vegan than if you
have a high protein animal protein diet
I mean there's lots of little papers and
little findings like that but there's
biggies the biggies that we can really
focus on once we're no longer distracted
or making an investment every day in our
faith spiritual or philosophical lives
the Transcendent walk the things that
are bigger than us whether it's
religious or not
our family lives and family is pretty
self-explanatory although it's not easy
our friendships deep real friendships
the by the way the family and
friendships they come together in one
single person which is your spouse and
then meaningful work work that serves
others and which you can create value
with your life these are the accounts
that we need to put our energy in every
single day and that will build and build
and build and build a better life now
we're not going to get to happiness
because that's a not a destination
that's a Direction but we'll get to in
Oprah coin this word in the books I'd
love she said the goal is happierness
Right nearness yeah yeah
um happy Earnest yeah I like that yeah
it on a surface level it all feels very
self-evident and obvious like of course
you want more friends and you want
family around and you want work that
that has meaning and you want a
connection to to some kind of uh Faith
tradition that gives your life a little
bit more meaning and you want to be
giving back right like it sounds so
intuitive and yet most people are bereft
of these these things because they
actually don't it is hard it's it's hard
mostly it's we don't quite believe it
and so we don't quite do it no a classic
case of this is most people say I wish I
were reading more stoic philosophy I
wish I were doing more meditation I wish
I were going to church like I say I do
whatever your thing is but they don't
actually get around to it because
they're not persuaded that this is as
important as getting your vegetables and
getting into the gym or or any of the
other things that are the basic
maintenance for building a healthier
better life or if you're busy and you're
time crunched and you got little kids
and you're working two jobs it just
feels like a nice to have yeah feels
like a nice to have it it's fundamental
with family life it's really interesting
too because we find that that family
relationships are more attenuated than
they've ever been in the data yeah
that's a big one let's talk let's spend
a little time on that because I think
that is a common thing
uh we're family maybe not the nuclear
family so much as the extended family is
just fraught with landmines and produces
a lot more unhappiness than happiness so
most people maybe not most people but a
lot of people would say actually
avoiding my extended family is better
for my happiness than engaging with them
yeah and and part of that is because we
have a tendency to
believe that that differences of opinion
are more important than they are you
know it's it's you know we have it we
in older times and you even go back to
the life of our parents they they didn't
lose track of their extended family
nearly as much as we do today because
they sort of needed them more there was
a sense of that these are my people and
and so they would put up with a lot more
nonsense than we do today plus there's a
tendency in Modern Life if so if people
disagree with you on things that I think
are relatively trivial like politics but
other people have turned into a
religious cult in America today to say
that if you know Uncle Jack you know he
likes Trump so you know that's a
personal attack on my identity and so
I'm not going to talk to him anymore
that's Insanity that's just ridiculous
you're losing your kin you're losing
your people you're losing people close
to you who have who have a deep
hardwired understanding of you and who
can bring something to your life if
you'll actually let them and we're
losing that and that's one of the
reasons that loneliness is just through
the roof yeah well with respect to
families it can be
complicated for those reasons but what's
beneath the surface there
are Decades of patterning right so that
when you go into a situation with that
challenging uncle
to use your example it's not just what
happens to be coming out of that
person's mouth in the moment it's a long
history
that then you know overrides you know
whatever part of your brain and and you
know it allows you you know prevents you
from having that mindful response and
then there's a cascading because that
because those patterns are so entrenched
then that's going to get a response and
then these things devolve very quickly
they can and that's actually a good
opportunity to use metacognition and and
chosen reactions and all of the
emotional self-management that we talked
about before you know when you're in old
relationships that have unconstructive
patterns in them you can reform those
relationships you can get new kinds of
you know muscle memory
um by by using your emotional
self-management skills through
metacognition and this is you know one
of the things that I talk about is what
should you be thinking about on the way
to Christmas dinner when you're going to
be around your relatives that you don't
like there's literally stuff that you
can actually think about you can
meditate and loving kindness meditation
on the good of the people that you're
about to see you can focus on the parts
of your life unrelated to the evening
and where you're incredibly grateful for
the things that have nothing to do with
this Christmas dinner you can literally
focus on your death focusing on your
death will improve your relationships
immediately so think about
I'm Not Dead all the way to the
Christmas dinner it'll be better there's
lots of ways that you can do this
because what you're trying to do is
you're trying to change your emotional
patterns you're trying to and you're
trying to condition yourself manage
yourself in a different way these should
be seen as opportunities as opposed to
just nuisances yeah and and and
disabusing yourself of the idea that
you're going to change them yeah all you
can manage is your own response to
whatever is happening and the more
neutral you can comport yourself in
those scenarios and also if you create a
little bit of distance almost
one tactic that I use is to pretend that
I'm watching everything go down on
television as opposed to experiencing it
to have a like a buffer zone yeah that
gives me a little bit more time for that
better metacognition there's one other
thing to keep in mind which is the
hardest thing to keep in mind of all but
it's the most constructive which is that
Uncle Jack might be right
yeah well that goes to the idea of
holding your your your your your your
ideas and how they inform your identity
a little bit more Loosely right yeah and
it's basically holding it's it's a tick
not Han you know the great Vietnamese
Buddhist monk and writer who wrote The
Miracle of mindfulness and many other
really really important books that we
should all be reading still today tiknot
Han said that one of the greatest areas
of attachment is attachment to opinion
he said an attachment of course is the
source of suffering it's the first Noble
law of Buddhism is that life is
suffering but really what that what that
meant was that life dukkha is actually
not suffering so much his life is
dissatisfaction and the reason for
dissatisfaction is our attachment to
these worldly things it gets back to the
conversation about satisfaction that we
had before one of the greatest areas of
this of dissatisfaction has everything
to do with our attachment to our
opinions our opinions are like are like
jewels in a box that we're counting
every single day as I think this and I
think that I'm completely sure of this
it's like
okay okay uh hold it lightly you know I
mean okay that's your opinion that's
fine you know and I have this I have a
reverse bucket list you know my reverse
bucket list is how I I I cross things
off it's what we talked about this
reverse bucket list and on my reverse
Bucket List when I turned 59 in May I
had half my political opinions hmm
because I was too attached um
interesting and so it doesn't mean it
gets really powerful it's an incredibly
timely right now and it doesn't mean I
don't believe these things it doesn't
mean I don't think these things it just
means I don't care that much about being
right and I'm a lot more willing when
people are I mean I crossed them off I
need more friends
well this is also like an amazing Arc
given you know your your career
trajectory from what you used to do yeah
you know where where self-identification
with a certain you know set of political
ideas is just that's I grew up in
Washington DC yeah you know how that
operates yeah yeah yeah I was never a
good fit for that because I've always
had lots of lots of friends across the
aisle but I thought that my opinions
were becoming too strong in a highly
electrified political environment and
and I think that they're mostly well
founded I mean I suffered through a PhD
in public policy analysis and you know
so I thought deeply about economic
policy and foreign policy and you know
but I'm I know I'm wrong on a lot of
things I just don't know what and I'm
not going to find out unless I'm around
people who disagree with me and so I
might as well find out first and not
last and so it just gives me a lot I
have to hold my opinions much more
lightly and love people who disagree
with me a lot more
and and so that was what was on my
reverse bucket list and it was a real
it's been a real game changer yeah I uh
I could use a little bit more of that in
my life and I think that that is a huge
thing in terms of unlocking dormant
happiness sure totally yeah I mean it's
like if if politics is getting in the
way of love in your life
bad trade that's a really bad I think
that's true of a lot of people oh yeah
being politically right and trading away
happiness you're stepping over 100 bills
to reach for nickels
it's a bad trade you're doing bad cost
benefit analysis and you know it's easy
it's easy to fall into because it's a
we've got a lot of culture Warriors that
are conscripting us into their war and
without paying attention they will they
will you know those guys are bad those
guys are evil those guys are stupid yeah
and you're like yeah yeah it's true
right
uh I heard you all know Harari say don't
be a profiteer in the culture War yeah
he'll be an arms Trader
yeah but it's so easy to get activated
in that space especially if you have an
opinion or you have a platform and then
you think about what your responsibility
is to engage with ideas publicly but I
just don't find it to be
productive to do that in the construct
of those social media environments
completely social media in particular
because it has no it has no Nuance
whatsoever and it turns out to be
ideally suited to fighting here's the
rule in general I mean I have opinions
you have opinions about politics and
life right I mean you apolog you have
opinions about what to eat what how to
how to exercise you know how to you know
how to conduct your affairs
your opinions are a gift
they're not a weapon
your your values should always be using
it used as a gift and never as a weapon
if you're ever using something that you
believe is a weapon you've eviscerated
its moral content and you've lost
you've already lost you're not gonna
you're not gonna you're gonna get people
already agree with you going yeah Rich
who needs it right you're not going to
convince anybody you're going to harden
down people's opinions with what
psychologists call the boomerang effect
which is pretty self-explanatory idea
when you tell somebody that they're a
they think they're old ideas even
more than they did before but if you use
them as a gift and you intend them as
such if your views are an expression of
your love for somebody else they will
usually be they may not pers they might
not persuade but you will improve the
relationship and that's really a good
thing to do
as a social scientist and somebody who's
spending a lot of time thinking about
happiness and deeply understanding the
crisis of declining happiness and the
rising rates of depression and the
relationship between those Trends and
what's happening on social media do you
see a solution for what ails us and what
might help us cohere as a democratic
country so that we can you know kind of
like kind of operate a little bit in a
in a healthier way yeah so I I am not a
catastrophist at all about what's going
on in the contrary I'm more hopeful that
I've been in a long time not necessarily
more optimistic optimism and hope are
different are very different optimism is
just a projection it's a prediction
about the Future Hope is that something
can be done I can do something about it
and when think when people are in pain
there's always opportunity opportunity
lies in pain and so our country right
now is being torn apart people are not
just not getting along we're not One
Nation an important way it's not the
first time it's not the worst time I
mean the 19th century was consistently
worse than it is today the late 1960s
were worse than they are today they were
you know political assassinations and
there's something like 900 political
bombings in the United States in in 1968
and 1969. I didn't know that yeah yeah
it's a Ken Burns the filmmaker told me
that at one point 700 900 some enormous
number that we wouldn't even be able to
comprehend at this point but we always
think it's the uniquely worst time
possible on the other hand we really are
not living together as one Society it
feels like a society in Decline as a
result of that
there really is only one solution to
that which is bringing more love to the
table that's the solution I mean I sound
like John Lennon or something you know
it's like all we need is love it's like
my whole career is boiling down to a you
know a John Lennon song but
but you know there's a lot of Truth a
lot of uh empirical truth to this as
well you know we need this complex
adaptive solution and none of the
solutions that we're bringing you know
I'm in a Vanquish a political solution
where I'm going to make sure that the
this party or that party holds both
houses of you know the house and the
Senate and the White House and stack the
Supreme Court and then we'll have a
30-year reign of progressive or
conservative policies that's that's not
going to do it we all know that's not
going to do it okay we'll head to the
bread and circuses of more Tech of AI of
a new social media platform of an easier
way to shop that makes things more fun
that's nothing more than distractions
what we need is to double and triple
down on the on the quality and content
of our relationships that's what we need
we need a much more Transcendent
understanding of the experience of life
that we have and I honestly believe the
reason I wrote this book The reason I'm
doing my work
the reason I'm alive I believe is
because that's the revolution I want to
try to format I want to love Rebellion
against all the things that we find and
the more misery there is the more
opportunity there is to actually bring
this about that's a that's an
interesting frame to look at it
um that's beautiful I mean you say at
the very end of the book you kind of
make this declaration about that
um and I and it left me thinking
this book provides tools for people to
practice this on an individual basis but
I also think in terms of of how do we
move culture and Society from a macro
perspective in this direction and one
thing I've come to understand and learn
is that you can't
browbeat people into changing their
habits but what you can do is create
systems that drive better choices more
conveniently for people like what blue
zones is doing in cities where they come
in and they create bike paths and they
get rid of vending machines and so the
unhealthy behavior is just a little bit
more difficult than it used to be and
it's conducive to the healthier choice
right are there things that can be done
beyond the individual things that we can
all learn about and practice through
this book that we could be thinking
about from a community or or Civic
perspective yeah one of the things that
I'm really keen on in my lab at Harvard
is dedicated to doing is creating more
happiness teachers throughout all the
society I don't mean people who you know
suffer through graduate school and all
that stuff I'm talking about people who
understand how their leadership platform
is one of actually bringing more
happiness to other people and the the
date the day gig the day job is just a
pretext for being able to do that so I
want Executives to understand this
technology and these ideas and and see
themselves as having the teachers I want
politicians to do I want Community
leaders I want people and families to do
this and if this actually became I
believe that this is something that we
could do because it's interesting and
it's fun and everybody likes it that if
people actually saw themselves that you
know that my job is lifting people up is
lightening the load of other people
around me if you can create that kind of
a movement of Happiness teaching and the
basis of this incredibly Winsome and the
science is so interesting and and and by
the way when you teach happiness you get
happier the secret to getting happier is
teaching happiness shouldn't this be in
every High School curriculum I mean
you're teaching it you're teaching one
class at Harvard Business School and
everybody wants to be in that class
obviously this is something that people
want and need right right but how about
we back it up and start teaching it when
younger people are before they've
decided what they think their career
trajectory should be to help inform
better decisions about how they're going
to invest all their attention and energy
for the rest of their life I agree you
know I'm working with a number of State
University Systems to make it a you know
required first year class in state and
universities so thousands and thousands
and thousands of kids who come into
college doing this I want to create a
high school class on this I want to have
you know ways that we can actually teach
many of these ideas to Children you know
at this point you know when you when you
write a book that can get to millions of
people or you have a platform like this
this is public education you're an
educator I mean you're you your teacher
and and this is how we're teaching these
ideas to people and everybody watching
us can take these ideas and teach them
to other people as well this is
incredible leverage so almost anything
where you're talking about these things
in public formally informally with a
structure of traditional teaching or not
is a way that we can actually create
more happiness education going around
and I think that's a movement that's
actually quite possible and it's
something that people want yeah that's
very exciting yeah I want to talk a
little bit about finding a way
to make your life about something more
than yourself and you know one thing
that I think we share is we both
uh have found ourselves in career paths
that we've crafted for ourselves where
we get to do this thing that we love
um and it takes care of ourselves and
our families but it's about more than
ourselves like I I really do uh you know
try to approach all of this from a
perspective of service how how can I
serve the audience how can I bring these
amazing individuals uh here so that I
can share their wisdom and experience
and enrich people's lives and I can't
think of anything more fulfilling or or
better uh or or or more exciting to do
and I'm incredibly grateful every single
day like I I just can't believe I'm
you're busting situation yeah yeah and I
want everybody to have their version of
that right but I'm imagining the person
who's listening to this saying well I'm
just you know I'm in my Q cubicle job I
you know I do the thing and it's very
difficult for me to figure out how this
is ever going to be about anything more
than a paycheck that allows me to pay my
bills there's a trap where I feel stuck
and I'm very sympathetic to that person
I think a lot of people suffer from that
so talk a little bit about how to build
more purpose and service into one's life
yeah whether through career or otherwise
yeah so career is one is one means for
doing that so let's talk about that
because work is one of the pillars of
the happiest life work that serves
others in which you feel like you're
earning your success it's easier for
some people than for others and by the
way there are a lot of people watching
who think
I like being an accountant and I'm sure
I'm glad I don't have to do rituals
podcast sure because that's a hard job
that I wouldn't know how to do and it
would be really really stressful and and
you know always being on the line to
read Arthur's book before I actually
interview Arthur it's just at least I
know what I'm doing in my and my work
ends at a particular time I mean I
talked to a guy who was driving me an
Uber driver a couple of months ago and
he's more than about about a year and a
half ago as a matter of fact he's in
this book and he said that the happiest
thing that he ever did was give up his
job that was sprawling all over the
place so that he could drive Uber
because when it's over it's over he
talks to people all day long and it
doesn't have any pressure except insofar
as he doesn't run into the guy in front
of him in traffic yeah and and So
Different Strokes is what it comes down
to but all of us can actually use our
our work as an opportunity to serve
other people in different ways we can
all lighten the load for others you know
so when you're you know your your boring
job in the cubicle in a day when you're
feeling really frustrated and you feel
like your autonomy has been violated and
all you really want to be doing is
playing in your band and and you're not
getting your big break and whatever it
is
you can actually get up and go get a cup
of coffee and bring it to the guy in the
next cubicle so it looks like you can
use a fresh cup of coffee your Dale
change
the truth is that the act of service per
se changes a person and the acts of
service they don't have to be grandiose
like you know this is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world you don't
have to have the most popular podcast in
the world it it's it's at the margin
it's the interaction that you actually
bring you know it's there's an old in in
the in the talmudic book of the
Sanhedrin which is you know part of the
ancient Jewish talmud there's the the
the Axiom that that in every man is the
whole world
and so the whole idea is that you serve
one person really and you've served the
whole world because all of us is the
whole world and it's it's a it's an
important way for us to understand in a
world that's diverse and diffuse and
confusing and do something beautiful for
someone I remember reading that for the
first time and and telling it to my wife
and I was writing a book about
charitable giving as early I was in
academic teaching at Syracuse in those
days she's like yeah yeah yeah you know
so instead of you know writing checks to
all these Charities and all the stuff
that we do we give away 10 of our income
and the whole deal and
he says why don't we why don't we adopt
an orphan
I'm like it's only a book
and and we did
we did be and it was Game Changer for us
it was a game changer it completely
changed our lives it was one person look
there's eight billion people who cares
but it changed the world it changed the
world that we live in it changed our
interaction our understanding of the
world there's do one little thing on the
basis of this and you've changed you've
turned the dial because this is not
about scale this is about people this is
about moments it's about what's written
on your heart at this very second hmm
that's beautiful
yeah in uh NAA it is said uh
they say our primary purpose is to say
is to stay sober and help another
alcoholic achieve sobriety
teach it you'll get it it's not help
Millions I know you know yeah no of
course of course this is the same it's
the same idea love is one person at a
time it's um there's the old joke that a
socialist is a man who loves Humanity
but only in groups of one million and
above
okay
I'm not trying to cast aspersions or
make a political statement a lot of us
have this mentality right it's like how
can I bring these big Ideas right there
right you know I need to have World
historical impact no what's born out of
ego and also envy and social media
comparison and seeing what other people
are doing and this desire or this need
to to make an impact and be noticed and
approved of as much as it is about the
act of service itself which can be small
Anonymous and is better if it's that way
that's what you know Mother Teresa used
to teach she said that you know that
that it's all in the little acts that's
where the magic of Love really comes is
is brought to bear is in the little
things that people don't see but that
that will actually change a moment in
somebody else's life will relieve stress
in somebody else's life at one
particular time and and everybody can do
that everybody can do that there is a
weird Ripple to this which is you can
practice this selfishly like you can
practice selfish selflessness like
understanding that service will make you
happier and will improve your life yeah
and improve the life of somebody else
you can do it for for reasons that have
nothing to do with the outcome for the
receiver and all about yourself you can
but if you're struggling you know with
trying to like get activated I'm not
saying that's the ideal perspective to
have but if somebody is not used to that
or unconvinced that this is going to
move the needle for them yeah one of the
things that you can do for you know
troubled teens for example really really
struggling is you put them into a
program where they're serving people who
are in even more trouble it's one of the
best ways you can inflict people toward
a better life for themselves is to you
know to put them into a place of service
when you find that the most effective
social service programs that keep people
sober and out of prison for example is
where they are the counselor of people
who have just been released back into
society it also disabuses you of your
self-obsession yeah yeah yeah to to get
into somebody else's life yeah you know
one of the ways that you know I made a I
made a commitment several years ago that
I was going to live these ideas and live
a better life
and one of the ways that I did that
publicly was identifying myself very
publicly with the science look if I'm
screwing up if I write a nasty tweet I'm
going to hear about it I mean I've
lashed myself to the Mast I use my
values as a gift and I suddenly I start
you know dropping F-bomb on Twitter and
say you jerk you know you I mean it's
it's it it's not let's just say it's not
on brand
you've been able to do that though yeah
because I commit myself to that's one of
the reasons I did I mean if you if you
publicly commit yourself to sobriety
this you've made the stakes higher you
know you've made the stakes higher for
doing the thing that's not going to help
you and be bad for you and be a short
run pleasure fix to to you know a moment
of misery in your life and so this is
one of the things that we can that one
of the things I recommend everybody do
is that you make a public commitment to
The Virtue that you seek
because that will ultimately pay the
biggest dividends in a life that's
that's disciplined and consistent right
um
family
friendship
work ideally work that is Tethered to
some form of service but um but but that
service can come in other areas of your
life and then the final pillar being
Faith right and I'm imagining the person
who's enjoying this conversation
thinking to themselves I get all those
other pillars like that makes perfect
sense but you lost me with the faith
part record I'm just gonna I'm gonna you
know I'm gonna put that one aside I'll
practice these other ones you know
Arthur and going to mass every day good
for him God bless him but not for me
yeah I got it I think that's because
there's a lot of people who've had
challenging uh experiences with
organized religion over the past uh and
have sort of you know cast that aside
and thought you know I'm I'm not going
back they're not there in their life and
the interesting thing faith is a
catch-all faith is just of it starts
with f so faith family friends you know
it kind of has a nice alliteration to it
but the truth is that what I mean by
that what the literature is very clear
on is not my faith it's not not my faith
but the point is that you need something
transcendental to your day-to-day
experience you will almost literally go
crazy if you focus on yourself day in
and day out and and if you don't have
something transcendental that zooms you
out on the Majesty of Life it'll be my
job my work my commute my money my lunch
my back pain my me me me it's
unbelievably tedious you need something
that zooms you out and and and and and
and
defocuses you and maybe that's reading
the stoic philosophers like our friend
Ryan holiday likes to do and and I like
to do too maybe that's that well getting
up Before Dawn and walking in nature for
an hour every day without devices maybe
that's your meditation practice maybe
that's
analyzing the structure of Bach fugues
maybe that's the faith of your youth but
you need something that's transcendental
to the day-to-day experience and that's
really what we're talking about and that
takes practice and work you have that
takes seriousness you have to approach
that with a certain kind of seriousness
that means usually the way that people I
recommend people start on that is
reading 15 minutes a day of Love wisdom
literature not you know Dale Carnegie
Hill that's good that's not the wisdom
literature that I'm talking about I'm
talking about Marcus Aurelius Epictetus
Aristotle's nicomachian ethics
dostoevsky's brothers karamazov real
stuff that has transcendental content to
it that helps you understand the context
of you and your life and the Majesty of
the great universe that is unreplaceable
in the happiness equation um
that's beautifully put and I think
another way of phrasing that is that
you're in charge of
locating
the nature of divinity in your own life
as you see fit when you come into 12
step they say you've got to find higher
power but it's a higher power of your
own of your own making right or your own
definition and you acknowledge nobody
since the higher power but yeah they
don't say what it is yeah it's like
that's up to you but but basically you
have got to figure out how to connect
your life to something bigger than you
that's right and there is something
bigger than you that puts you in
perspective helps you understand
that you aren't the center of everything
thank God you know here's the weird
thing people are afraid to find out
they're not the center of everything but
when they do it's just the biggest
relief
right finally the pressure is off you
know finally I can actually get on with
the serious business of being part of
this incredible life you know stand in
awe of what it actually is and that's
really really important so you know
doing the reading um doing the practice
and you know having a contemplative
practice having wisdom reading I
recommend that people think deeply
deeply about what their values are and
then trying to live according to them
really consistently with that you know
writing out what is my what is the order
of operations of everything I'm trying
to do I mean I have a I have a you know
I have a startup that's doing all this
work and I've got my my lab at the
University and all that but there's an
order of operations that I've that I'm
clear on and people who work with me are
very clear on the order of operations
that's you know one two three four and
all the work that we do has to do all
four and it has to be in that order and
then I hold myself accountable to that
that's really part of the spiritual
journey as well is finding the
consistency of curly um is just you know
it's it's just deeper and deeper and
deeper and deeper the further you go and
one of the things that he talked about
is the secret to happiness is knowing
what you believe and living according to
it
it doesn't mean you have to live the way
I think you should live but knowing what
you actually think is right and knowing
what you think is wrong and the
difference between those two things and
acting consistently with those values
and unhappiness will come either if you
don't know the difference between right
and wrong in your views or you don't act
consistently with your own views and so
writing down that mission statement
saying am I living according to this
mission statement I have a spreadsheet
that I keep literally in my life of the
different micronutrients of my happiness
equation and a lot of it's ethical am I
living up to these am I living up to my
order of operations and I rate myself on
it wow that's so important it is wow
that's quite rigorous and so what do you
how do you navigate dips in that like if
you find yourself not living up if
you're if they're if you're out of
alignment between a certain value and a
certain Behavior or action what is the
process of working through
um the emotions of that and then
correcting it so I confess it
and I make a commitment to to be better
with a with a a course of action to make
it better so I take a series of steps
and and I make commitments to myself and
what I'm going to do differently so for
example I'll look through it and you
know twice a year I'm really updating
the spreadsheet mostly on my birthday
but on the off birthday or the half
birthday as well and I'll see in there
that I'm not getting good grades with my
wife I'm not getting good grades now I
know my wife if I'm not getting good
grades it's me and the reason is because
I'm not on my game I'm you know being a
little bit too much Arthur Brooks a
little bit too much it's like yeah I
think I'll do I think I'll do 49 weeks
this year I think I'll do you know more
speeches this year I think yeah I'll do
that that sounds cool mostly because I'm
following these Idols money power honor
admiration all these things that I don't
admire about myself
I say okay and it's actually taken a
toll on my relationship with Esther
so I write that down I confess it to her
I usually go to the confessional and
Catholic I get to confess it to a priest
too and I make a commitment I'm going to
make it better and actually put together
a plan and I I check in more regularly
and I see whether or not I'm bringing my
score back up
do you think that the person you choose
to be in life partnership with
is maybe the most important decision a
person is going to make
if I name the top three decisions it
would be one of them at least you know
um it's uh
now it's interesting because the way you
phrase that is who you choose
um and there's a kind of a cosmic aspect
to that it almost feels I bet in your
life too that you feel like she was
chosen for you oh it a 100 yeah that's
what happened yeah and no doubts about
that yeah I mean there's this and and
the truth is we know intellectually that
there's any number of people that you
could have had a successful marriage
with but you took
one that was in the zone and made it
perfect and that's really where the
beauty of it is is in the project of
making this thing really good together
so like anything else it's not a
question your romantic partnership is
not a question of getting lucky
it's better to be good than lucky it's a
more important to work hard than to have
good luck it's a funny thing about all
Lucky people they tend to be really hard
workers and disciplined people it's not
weird and and everybody I know is a good
marriage it's like wow so lucky you
found your soul mate no no you made your
soul mate together you made your
soulmate so yeah and it's not a decision
it's a series of decisions until the day
you die it's decision after decision you
talk a lot in the book about digital
versus analog experiences and the
context of of friendships but also uh
romantic relationships I'm thinking of a
younger generation a generation beneath
us right that
is basically leveraging dating apps
right for
romantic opportunities and that's just
the way that the culture that that's how
it goes now you know as I'm sure your
kids used it but like yeah yeah I mean
it's all about that right and uh I
wondered if you had any words of wisdom
for somebody who is engaged in that
process about how to you know do it in
the most healthy way yeah so one of the
things that we find is despite the fact
that finding people in the Online
Marketplace is easier than it's ever
been before and there's more Choice than
there's ever been before people are
lonelier and they're more frustrated by
dating they're they feel like they're
they're less successful in dating than
people said they were in the 1980s when
you and I were dating
um and and there's a reason for that it
has to do with the fact that we don't
use the technology optimally
I mean ideally people meet without
technology but it's harder to do and
it's not it's not a legitimate thing for
me to ask our viewers yeah to do that
because you're where are you going to
meet you talk to somebody in a bar and
they think you're an Ax Murderer at this
point or so if you're not religious
you're not going to go meet somebody in
church who you know shares your values
where do you meet people is where it
comes down to school maybe you know but
even at Harvard a lot of people a lot of
my students will tell me that people
don't typically date they're fellow
students it's just not done it seems
weird to a lot of people today which is
strange because it's like why else do
you go to college yeah yeah that is
that's the point I guess you're in
Cambridge and Boston so there's other
opportunities but for a lot of people in
school like they're in a small town in
the middle of nowhere but they're using
the apps and the apps have two big
problems number one is the Paradox of
choice
which means that you have too much
choice and the result of that is that
you get the feeling that there's always
somebody better and so you're always
wondering and this gets back to all
these studies you know the studies that
show that you know there's one famous
study where half the half the sample
when they bought a car it was deal is
final and the other half is they could
turn it in for any reason or no reason
within the first six months the first
half was happier with their car
purchased in the center of the sample
why because the second half was
reassessing their car purchase over and
over and over and over and over and
noticing all kinds of imperfections
whereas the first is like they made
their piece with and so I love this car
this car is awesome and that's the same
thing it did when we're actually making
decisions about dating or being with
somebody in a relationship who's
imperfect the car is imperfect the
spouse is imperfect that's just the way
it is and and if you've all you can
always try again try again try again try
again the Paradox of choice will degrade
the the quality of the choice in your
mind that's number one
the bigger and worse part is that what
we use the technology for is to curate
our choices on the basis of
compatibility we look for people who are
just like us because we're vain you know
we're so egotistical and and we wind up
ironically with people that we're not
very attracted to but who are basically
siblings which is you know my adult kids
would note is that's not hot yeah I
don't want somebody who's but we look
for somebody who's just like us because
vanity would say that that's the best
possible match but then we don't like
them as much there's even biological
data I mean the famous t-shirt sniffing
study I'm sure you know that study right
no actually I don't it's a study from
the mid 1990s and where you know the the
researchers they asked men to wear on a
campus
um to wear t-shirts for 48 hours without
taking them off sweating into them you
know not working out but just going
about their daily life and they would
take those t-shirts and put them into
shoe boxes poke holes in the shoe boxes
and get them to random women and ask the
women to rate the attractiveness of the
men who had won the t-shirts simply on
the basis of how the t-shirts smell they
found that the men who were most
different from them in terms of their
immunological profile were the most
attractive why because the olfactory
bulb in the brain has all kinds of
information that gives us Beyond just
that smells like steak or whatever it
happens to be or that smells like
garbage or something is giving me a
sense of disgust we notice we we take
information that shows all sorts of
biological information about other
people and we want people who are more
different than us we find people who are
more different than us sexy because
we're more likely to have healthy kids
if they have a different immunological
profile which gives more repertoire to
more right there's a natural selection
argument here that is favoring
differentiation yeah so with the apps if
you're looking for people who are just
like you with your background in your
college and your political opinions that
you're going to get your sib and you're
going to be like I don't know I just
can't find anybody I'm attracted to
that's why you need base level values
which doesn't include politics if you're
very religious find somebody in your
religion that's fine if you need to live
in a particular place because your
family that's fine but everything on top
of that look for difference
personality difference background
difference values differences that's
what's going to attract you that's the
adventure that's when romance is fun and
so you have to use the apps differently
say I'm like this I want somebody who's
going to complete me by being different
write that in the profile hmm
see if you get any hits who knows yeah I
know yeah I'm just thinking how is that
going to go I don't know I've never been
on a dating plan my guess is that's so
good me neither because you know we're
old but but
um thank God you know I hope you never
have to be or me either I I live
vicariously through some friends who
kind of tell me what's going on there
yeah and my kids don't it doesn't sound
like fun one of my sons met that his
wife had an internship at my company
um he's 25 and a father already my 23
year old also married met his wife on
the beach in San Clemente and and you
know my little girl is 20 is not doing
that yeah raising Catholic Catholic
stuff yeah I guess right oh my god
um in in your experience teaching these
young people you know what what is what
is another thing that you think young
people have upside down when it comes to
happiness Beyond like the kind of low
hanging fruit that we understand of
chasing money and power Etc all of my
students in fact almost all young people
think they're going to get happier as
they get older that they're just
naturally going to get happier as they
get older and the reason is because they
think the circumstances of their lives
are going to improve and they are and
that that is the main reason that
they'll be happier they'll have the job
they want and the career they want and
the money they need and the if they want
if they want a family they're going to
have a family but circumstances because
I can't keep No Satisfaction that's the
homeostatic principle is what we call it
that those things actually don't last
the truth is that most people they have
a tendency to trade off enjoyment for
meaning all the way from their early 20s
until the early 50s and that means
they're moment-to-moment happiness Falls
you enjoy your life Less in your 30s and
in your 20s you enjoy your life Less on
average in your 40s than you did in your
30s you have more meaning but meaning is
long-term and it comes later and so what
happens is that people are shocked to
find they think their happiness is going
to go up and up and up and up and up and
it's going to max out at some point this
is going to come back down the truth is
it's going to slightly decrease from the
early 20s you know the early 50s and
then it goes up a lot usually until
about age 70 then it breaks up into two
groups and whether you keep going up or
start going back down again depends
everything on the decisions you made
when you were younger and they don't
know that um
yeah that makes perfect sense I mean
when you're young and you're ambitious
you're more than willing to delay not
just gratification but happiness in the
pursuit of building something that you
think has meaning that's going to
provide happiness later and and Overlook
the need for having any happiness in
your life in the present moment yeah and
although people still seem to have a
good time in their 20s they better time
than I'm having yeah
I mean and from that in that kind of
like daily enjoyment perspective well
people in the 20s where enjoyment really
starts to be defraight is when they have
kids that's one enjoyment of
moment-to-moment experience tends to go
down the meaning goes through the roof
but enjoyment goes way down enjoyment of
your marriage goes down when you first
have kids enjoyment of your leisure time
goes way down when you have kids and
just because it's hard and it's
stressful and people in the 30s and 40s
they're balancing
making payments and raising kids and you
know trying to stay married and and
having a job and having a boss and
having a commute and trying to get into
a house that you can afford is
incredibly stressful and so enjoyment
tends to be quite low even though
meaning because of all the decisions
you're making in your life is going up
and you you you benefit from all those
meaning decisions in your 50s typically
back when your enjoyment has come back
so everybody's a little bit different
but by the time your kids come along you
start making and again it's still
worthwhile because having kids net net
raises life you know purpose and meaning
over the over the over the span of your
life by a lot yeah but also that moment
when you partner up and you start having
kids that's when you start to detach
from your friendships yeah and then
there's a long period of time at least
as the data shows with men and in my own
life experience it's not until much
later when you start to realize like you
haven't talked to your friends in a long
time and you're lonely yeah and and and
the phone is heavy because you haven't
talked to them in a long time and what
would that look like and How's that
gonna how am I gonna work that back into
my life and I think a lot of people just
ignore it or you know wish it away and
end up more and more lonely and I think
what was really something I really
appreciated in the book was you're you
saying like this is work yeah like are
you committed to that work right this is
important and and you have to do it and
yes it's probably going to be
uncomfortable if you are one of those
people that's right that's right and you
have to take it seriously enough to put
in the time see the people that you're
most you see the most often are actually
your co-workers most people will spend
more time with their co-workers even
than their family and they'll even say
they're you know they're my friends but
they're deal friends not real friends
typically you can have real friends at
work that's great you know I mean 17 of
marriages actually started in the
workplace that's great but mostly you've
got these deal friends and if you
stopped working together you probably
wouldn't keep hanging out and you hang
out because you kind of like that person
and then the people that you really love
that you met in college you hung out
hung out with and you were going to be
friends forever and you haven't talked
to them for two months and three months
and six months and and and that's one of
the reasons that some of the loneliest
people in America typically have been 60
year old men and 60 of them say their
best friend is their wife whereas 30 of
their wives say their best friend is
their husband
contemplate that statistic I'm just
thinking I'm just thinking about your
life like you're traveling 48 weeks out
of the year you're on the road to
somewhere you're married your kids are
out of the house so that probably makes
it easier but what is a day in the life
look like for you and and how do you
make room for yeah friendships
friendships and friendships and family
for that matter
um so I I mean I have routines that that
protocols that make sure that I don't
you know fall down on these things too
terribly much I don't have as many
friends as I would if I lived in one
place all the time to be sure but most
of my friends don't live in Boston I
mean I have my my closest friend lives
in Atlanta as a matter of fact and I've
moved all over the place you know I've
moved my wife and I moved 20 times in
the past 32 years we just and you know
Europe and west coast and the East Coast
et cetera et cetera just sort of chasing
our Fortune but you know my friend Frank
in Atlanta he's he you know he's stable
and and we talk usually we talk
seriously about once a week
um and we we sometimes have a pretext
like we need something we need to talk
about because something we're doing
together in business but typically we
don't ever get to the business so how
you doing you know and and and he'll ask
me something he has a question he's been
wanting to ask me that's something deep
you know something heavy that's on his
mind or I have some advice that I need
from him something that's kind of
bugging me and I know that Frank's going
to give me good advice and I set aside
45 minutes or an hour because that's how
long the conversation is going to take
and I have to schedule that because I'm
busy yeah when it with my family you
know I'm I'm usually out three between
two and four nights a week so I'm
usually home more nights than I'm there
and every morning when I'm at home
um my wife and I start the day but I I
work out from five to six in the morning
and then at 6 45 we go to mass together
that's one of the things we do together
instead of praying with your spouse is
incredibly intimate and you you uh
didn't you buy a house that because it
was close
you know that's a mute right and you and
I wanted to cut down on the commute time
so it's a very practical decision it's
not like I'm such I'm that churchy but
and then we usually spend the evening
together we we we we have meditative
prayer that we have together before we
go to bed together at night when I'm
home and these are very intimate moments
um and and so you have to maximize right
I hate to get into the quality time
versus the quantity time
but it's not untrue and you have to be
disciplined about how the way the way
that you're pursuing these relationships
because they'll get away from you I mean
the tyranny of the Urgent and and all
the adventures and fun things that I get
in my life and you get in yours will get
in the way of the things that are
actually more important for a long-term
happy life
yeah I imagine the opportunities that
get dangled in front of you are are
amazing and tempting and you probably
want to say yes to all of them it's one
of the things that I've done in my own
Enterprise in my own company is that I'm
not CEO I have a CEO of my company and
she's fantastic she's I mean she's just
great and one of the she knows me really
well and I don't see the opportunities
she does she feels them for you because
she knows that if somebody comes
directly to me or also be like yes yeah
yes yes I will go to New Zealand next
Tuesday yes yes you know because of my
dopamine we'll go right this is the
thing you know my dopamine is like set
on extra high for the anticipation of
reward that comes from Adventures I love
adventures and new stuff and going
places and talking to people about
happiness I just want to do it so much
that if somebody comes to me I will you
know have an irrational decision I'll be
highly limbic right or something really
amazing about the fact that
perhaps the most challenging impediment
to your own happiness are all the
opportunities to you know spread the
gospel of Happiness across the world
that irony has not been lost on my wife
Esther yeah
which leads me to kind of the final
thing I wanted to talk to you about on
that that topic of teaching that you
touched on earlier the book ends with a
sort of call to action like listen if
you do this and your life gets better
like here's how you can help other
people with this it really is a populist
kind of
um cattle prod to get people to think
about not just it's again an i versus me
thing like think of this not just for
yourself but how much good you could do
especially if you're lacking that sense
of that purpose or meaning in your life
like here it is that's right that's
right it is and and even more you can
bring this to other people and if you do
it will be with you forever the secret
to getting happier is teaching happiness
that I mean it's like I hate to admit it
but it's absolutely true that I teach
happiness because I want to be happy
and the more I teach you the happier I
get my happiness is literally risen by
60 in the last four years how do you
come up with that percentage because
I've got I've got the diagnostic tests
that I look dynamically because I'm
giving my students consistently these
tests and I'd take it myself to see
actually what my progress is and I know
how to answer the questions
honestly and I've seen incredible
progress because I'm thinking about
these ideas I'm sharing these ideas I'm
urging people to adopt these practices
and I adopt these practices myself my
column in the Atlantic every week it has
three things that you can do to put the
science into action and I'm I'm my
column is usually eight weeks out so I'm
writing for eight weeks from now and I'm
trying things I'm I'm I'm happiness
hacking all the time to see if these
things actually work to change mood to
change attitude some of these things
will become permanent parts of my
routine but I don't recommend these
things unless they actually work in my
own life and the result is
man I mean it's not perfect but my life
is better I mean it's just better than
when I was running a company when I was
running the think tank in Washington DC
I look back on those years and
there was some there were some good
times and there were some laughs and
there were some light times but I just
can't believe it took me this long to
get to these the things I'm doing now
you literally had to get you know
basically make your life about trying to
understand this yeah to fix it for
yourself yeah and now spread it to other
people yeah my my natural Baseline
happiness level is significantly lower
than most of my students
um and you know surprising to hear that
yeah and people often are because you
know it's like they think happiness is
like athletic ability which is if you're
teaching it you're a professional at it
you must be naturally gifted at it and
the truth is that I actually know almost
everybody who does science of Happiness
as a social scientist or neuroscientist
because it's a pretty small community of
people
it's all me search not research
everybody who's studying it doesn't of
course yeah that's not surprising to
hear it that's not surprising here what
is the the science that's coming out now
that excites you or maybe a better
question might be
what is the research that you would like
to see that would unlock a new level of
this for you so for the longest time
it's a great question and for the
longest time happiness was an almost
exclusively psychological discipline and
psychology was almost completely
disconnected from Neuroscience for the
longest time and it's only been
relatively recently that these these
bodies of work have started to interact
when I started I mean I wrote my first
book on happiness in 2008 and there's
not one single Neuroscience paper that's
cited in that book now you've read this
book you know that there's a ton of
Neuroscience there's so much
Neuroscience in this book that I had my
colleague Josh Green at Harvard one of
the very distinguished neuroscientists
read it to make sure that because I'm
not a neuroscientist to make sure that
I'm reading the science correctly and
I'm interpreting the the the the
findings correctly there's an
increasingly increasing convergence
between neuroscience and Social
Psychology social science in general
it's unbelievably exciting back in the
day Psychology was I mean biology was
just psychology you could will your pain
away and you needed to actually have
therapy and talk through things you
understood
more and more and more we're
understanding a lot of psychology is
actually biology and that's incredibly
empowering because once we understand
the structure of what's going on between
our ears the psychology takes on so much
more meaning because it has structural
implications for the way the habits and
you know that it's it's there's a reason
that you know then an ultra endurance
athlete is talking to a social scientist
because our worlds converge when we
understand that there's a seamlessness
between the the physiological and the
psychological parts of what I'm talking
about and I want that to go forward even
more you know when I first started
teaching this stuff it was probably a
few glancing references to
neuromodulators
a little bit about the prefrontal cortex
and some mentions of the limbic system
now 30 of what I teach is neuroscience
wow yeah yeah yeah it's it's just does
that make you want to go back and get
another PhD well I practically I mean so
right now I'm reading so much
Neuroscience for my column and for my
books that it's you know I probably have
the level of knowledge of a rising
Junior and Neuroscience at MIT or
something which is to say I have to have
appropriate humility
I'm not a neuroscientist like huberman
you know somebody who has you know the
super deep knowledge in it but I can
read the literature and I can't
interpret it in the context of what I'm
talking about and I always always have
it vetted by the pros is the whole thing
that's super exciting I think what's
exciting about that is the agency that
it gives the everyday person once
they're they're sort of educated up on
the implications of that with tools to
affect their own biology with that
understanding of how the brain and the
nervous system works yeah I mean for the
longest time you know went before these
two literatures
intersected people would say what's the
relationship between Fitness and
happiness I'm like oh now we know now we
know Fitness diet and fitness exercise
lowers negative effect it doesn't raise
positive affect it lowers negative
affect that's the reason that people who
have naturally low negative affect can't
stay on an exercise regime because they
have nothing to lower they don't feel
the benefit from it yeah they don't feel
the psychological benefit that comes
from managing their negative affect like
this we wouldn't have known this if and
if these literatures were not starting
to intersect and I'm still at 27 or
whatever it is what am I at 18 no yeah
I'm 27 on the negative app yeah but all
the exercises well the point is it's
always going to come back because you're
managing it you're managing it you're
not going to get a permanent diminution
in your negative affect but that's one
of the that's why I spend five to six in
the gym it's because I'm because I have
to manage my negative affect because
that's that's where I am on The Pianist
yeah that mad scientist is a mad
scientist yeah it's better to be a mad
scientist who's lifting weights turns
out that's true yeah for every here
here's your life protocol B on which box
you you know which yeah which uh which
person and we can go away we can do tons
more on that than we have we can do way
more than we've done on that and that's
what I want the next 10 years of this to
look like where you're working my work
are intersecting more and more and more
and more so any young person out there
looking for a career trajectory
yeah Neuroscience neuroscience and
psychology psychology yeah we do a
Psychology major with the Neuroscience
certificate at a good University or vice
versa and then doing graduate work where
you're we're very well versed in both
and do it at Harvard and come work in my
lab there you go yeah all right
um
thank you thank you that's really
fantastic I just love the work and
you're by the way as a you know
you get to talk to me once a year I get
to talk to you I get to listen to you
every week so I appreciate that I'm
listening to you and I'm reading your
stuff like you're you're out there but
you're soon about to be everywhere I
think by the time this podcast drops
you're gonna be a household name in a
way that you you weren't previously I
think to the turbo charging power of the
Oprah effect and I know you've got a lot
of exciting stuff uh coming up in terms
of the book and the rollout and all of
that so I appreciate you taking time to
come here
um the book build the life you want
co-written by Oprah Winfrey is uh
probably going to be inescapable shortly
I hope I hope it's uh so it's uh I hope
it's positive and pleasant as well that
was great you did you did a great job
and we were chatting beforehand like
it's only 200 Pages clearly you had to
really strip this down and and and make
it it's a very easy read and with all
the knowledge that you have it would be
very easy for you to make this dense and
complicated yeah I mean my I have a
Professor practice at Harvard and that
means that my job is not just bringing
practice to the classroom but bringing
academic ideas to the public and so this
is uh this is really what I'm dedicated
to doing even in my academic work is
bringing Big Ideas to the public sphere
yeah well you're a gift to the world my
friend and I can't wait to see what you
do next thanks I just appreciate you I
think the work you're doing is vital and
super important and just the way that
you you walk your talk and comport
yourself as an as an example of of what
you're teaching I think is really
impressive and magnificent Thank you
Rich I appreciate it a lot and um thanks
for what you're doing too yeah for me
and for everybody all right part three
at some point really yeah thanks thanks
peace